Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Leute, ich bin gleich da.
Ich muss noch kurz mein Brötchen fertig futtern und meine Pillen nehmen.
1-2 Minuten bin ich am Start.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
und dieser spielt gleich haben wir noch ein tostbrot und straff fertig voran
irgendwie habe ich ein bisschen lange gepennt
So, fertig.
Aber ein bisschen was entspannenderes an.
Ob die Lautstärke passt?
Das Windhaus ändert das ja laufen.
So, da bin ich.
Oh, ich habe meine Pillen vergessen, die muss ich jetzt noch schnell nehmen.
Trinken.
so
hinstellt
oh
excellent
so
ready
reboot
reboot time
ja, wo wir gerade dabei sind
reboot, reboot, reboot
das hätte ich auch machen können
während ich gefressen habe.
Ah gut, so ist es.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Bisschen kühl, oder?
Was ist denn hier los?
Jetzt hier in kurzer Hose und ohne Hemd.
Irgendwie bisschen kühl.
Was ist da los?
Anzeige ist raus
Naja gut, ich hab die Tür zu
Ich hab zwei
Fette Rechner an
Es wird allein schon deswegen aufheizen
Hier drinnen
Mint oder Arch
In 2026
Cashy ist Arch, ja
Aber
Ist eher die Frage
welche Zielgruppe.
Also man
Cache kannst du auch als Einstiegssystem verwenden,
wobei ich jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen würde, dass es mein
absolut favorite
Einstiegssystem ist,
kann man aber machen.
Ist immerhin noch ein Arch drunter, also da muss man sich
teilweise schon mit den ein oder anderen Sachen beschäftigen.
Als reines Einstiegssystem
so komplett, auch für jemand, der keine Ahnung
von Linux hat und auch nicht großartig Bock hat,
sich damit zu beschäftigen, ist Mint
wahrscheinlich die bessere Wahl
als CacheOS.
bis SteamOS richtig raus ist.
SteamOS ist doch schon richtig raus.
Halt für...
für Steam-Kisten.
Die sagen ja auch, sie empfehlen nicht,
das auf andere Hardware zu benutzen.
Würde ich auch nicht machen.
Aber wenn du ein Betriebssystem zum Spielen suchst,
hast du die Auswahl zwischen...
Also letztendlich funktioniert das überall mittlerweile, ja.
Aber so die beliebtesten Systeme für Linux Gaming sind CacheOS, Nubara, was so Fedora basiert.
Fedora ist auch nicht schlecht mittlerweile.
Und als drittes, was war das dritte Chat?
Jetzt müssen wir mal auf die Sprünge helfen.
CacheOS, Nubara und
Bist du Max?
Ne, ich bin Wobblos
Ne, ne, ne, nicht Mint
Äh, wartet mal, wartet mal
Gaming, Linux
Nubara
CacheOS
Besside
Besside meine ich
Oder so
Ja
Das sind sowohl die beliebtesten Linux-Distributionen
Wenn es rein um Gaming geht
Aber ganz im Ernst
Es funktioniert auch so
Also du kannst das mit mehr oder weniger jeder
Distribution mittlerweile machen
Wann kommen mal wieder Videos auf YouTube?
Ja
Wenn ich mich danach fühle
Das geht gerade nicht so richtig.
So.
Zack.
Ja, gestern und heute.
Wobei, heute geht es.
Gestern ging es mir wieder ein bisschen schlechter.
Aber es wird immer weniger.
Es wird immer weniger.
Schlimm.
Es hält immer kürzer und immer größere Abstände.
Also.
Excellent.
Übrigens.
Chat.
Soll ich euch mal ein Geheimnis verraten?
Ihr dürft es aber noch nicht weiter verraten
Bis morgen
Morgen dürft ihr es weiter verraten
Ihr verratet nichts, oder?
Chat
Nichts verraten, okay?
Okay, gut.
Nächsten Monat
gibt's ein paar
Sponsor-Streams
mit
drei oder von drei
Herstellern,
von denen ihr wahrscheinlich alle schon was gehört habt.
Was auch thematisch
ziemlich gut passt
zu meinem Stream-Inhalt.
Ultimate Nass Stream.
Ja, mit Nass machen wir auch was.
Ihr werdet das Montag sehen,
weil Montags werde ich meinen Channel Banner anpassen.
Und dann gibt es einen Monat lang
Sponsor...
Also, es sind die stinknormalen Streams.
Es erinnert sich an den Streams nichts.
Die Streams sind nur
sponsort und ich mache ab und zu mal Sellout.
Aber es passt thematisch
und das Beste ist,
nein, nein, nicht NordVPN,
und das Beste ist, es gibt sogar
Affiliate Links,
wo es
Hardware günstiger gibt.
Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Also die Hardwarepreise sind wirklich nicht verkehrter.
Und ich meine, günstige Hardware kann man aktuell immer gebrauchen.
So.
Dann machen wir mal kurz hier Betriebssystem-Update.
Erstmal aufwachen.
In der Wüste.
Ne.
Es ist nicht Genshin Impact.
Wie gesagt, es hat mit Games nichts zu tun.
Zwei Hardwarehersteller und ein
Hardware-Online-Shop.
Was hältst du eigentlich von der Aussage
von den VPN-Anbietern, dass sie den Traffic
verschlüsseln, wenn der Traffic eh durch TLS
Verschlüsselung ist. Ich hab mal ein Video
gemacht.
Da hab ich mich
hier, da hab ich mich
drüber ausgelassen.
Aber
letztendlich ist
das, also vieles
der Werbung von VPN-Anbietern ist
gefühlte Sicherheit, ja.
Also entweder bringt's nicht wirklich was,
was die Verschlüsselung angeht, aber
das Ding ist halt, was?
Also VPN hat ja schon seine Daseinsberechtigung.
VPN hat seine Daseinsberechtigung
zum Umgehen von irgendwelchen
Geoblock-Dingern. Das ist auch so ziemlich
mehr oder weniger
der Hauptanwendungszweck,
würde ich mal sagen,
dass man da
seine Herkunft, beziehungsweise seine
IP-Verschlüsselung verschleiern kann.
Wenn man rein anonym irgendwie surfen will, kann man auch den Tor-Browser verwenden.
Bei VPN-Anbietern ist halt das Problem, das Ganze steht und fällt damit, dass du dem VPN-Anbieter vertrauen musst.
Also sprich, wenn du das VPN verwendest, so wie die Anbieter das sagen, so nach dem Motto hier, zum anonymen unterwegs sein,
dann musst du natürlich erstmal prinzipiell dem VPN-Anbieter vertrauen.
Also sprich, glaubst du dem, dass der keine Logs speichert?
Glaubst du dem, dass der keine Logs rausrückt oder sonst was in der Richtung?
Und ganz ehrlich, den meisten VPN-Anbietern glaube ich das nicht.
Wenn da von passender Stelle die Anfrage kommt, werden sie schon was rausrücken.
Ob sie es zu Werbezwecken verwenden, keine Ahnung.
Aber du musst dem VPN-Anbieter vertrauen.
Das nächste ist, es gibt eine...
mal mal falsches gefühl von sicherheit weil wenn man jetzt den den werbeaussagen vertraut dass sie
sagen ja sie sind hier super anonym unterwegs keiner kann den traffic einsehen und sonst was
das stimmt ja auch nur bedingt ja der traffic ist noch mal extra verschlüsselt ok zwischen dem
eingang zum vpn also prinzip zwischen euch und dem ausgang also quasi von euch
bis zum ausgang des vpns danach ist das wiederum verschlüsselt das einzige was
natürlich ändert ist die absender ip ist dann die halt von irgendeinem vpn server
okay meinetwegen aber der inhalt wenn das selbst also wenn euer traffic selber
nicht nochmal verschlüsselt ist, ist er ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo er aus dem VPN rausgeht,
auch ganz normal lesbar.
Das heißt, an der Stelle passiert da schon mal gar nichts.
Und wenn ihr da irgendwelche sensible Sachen drin stehen habt, die unverschlüsselt sind,
kann man das an der Stelle ohne Probleme abgreifen und höchstwahrscheinlich auch Rückschlüsse
auf euch ziehen.
Also, das ist nur so ein halbes Ding.
Der VPN hat natürlich seine Daseinsberechtigung, aber man darf jetzt nicht dieser Sache glauben
mit, es ist hier die
ultimative Waffe gegen alles.
Was die VPN-Anbieter da gerne erzählen.
Also das ist Blödsinn. Wenn der Traffic
eh schon verschlüsselt ist, kann das auch sonst
keiner mitlesen.
Wie gesagt, hauptsächlich dient VPN ja
dazu, seine Absender-IP, beziehungsweise
da, wo man herkommt, zu verschleiern.
Das kannst du natürlich
mit TLS-Verschlüsselung nicht machen.
Aber ansonsten...
Also ganz ehrlich,
mir fallen für VPN
eigentlich
eine legit
Anwendungssache ein
und das ist
Geoblockaden irgendwie zu umgehen
also falls
irgendwelche Streaminganbieter
nur Zugriff aus einem bestimmten
Land erlauben
ja zum Beispiel, es gibt zum Beispiel eine Sache
dafür ist es
ganz sinnvoll, ich nehme jetzt mal was,
ich verwende,
wenn man gerne sich
Radsportrennen anguckt,
da gibt es meistens in dem Land,
wo die stattfinden,
sei es jetzt Italien, Spanien, Belgien,
Frankreich, da gibt es meistens
kostenlose Streams.
Die sind aber geblockt
aus anderen Ländern
und wenn man das gucken will, ist ein VPN ganz nice.
Ansonsten braucht man irgendwelche Streaming-Abos,
die das übertragen.
ist auch schon wieder unglaublich kompliziert sowas überhaupt gucken zu können teil für narsch
dafür ist das sinnvoll ja oder auch wenn leute bei innenstreaming anbieter sind bei netflix
sonstigen die geo zeug umgehen wollen wobei die da ja auch mittlerweile gegen ankämpfen ja mit
blocken ip von vpn anbietern dafür ist das sinnvoll der andere anwendungsfall für die
das wahrscheinlich ganz viele leute benutzen werden ist linux distribution aus dem usernet
nicht runterladen, zum Beispiel.
Und du hast recht, da habe ich jetzt gar nicht
dran gedacht. Dafür ist das auch
sinnvoll. Stimmt, da habe ich gar nicht
dran gedacht. An den ganzen Telekom-Mist habe ich überhaupt nicht
gedacht. Stimmt, dafür ist es natürlich auch
sinnvoll, wenn man
ein bisschen das Routing beeinflussen will,
wo lang der Traffic geht.
Weil normalerweise werden die
Pakete halt so geroutet, wie es
die jeweiligen Anbieter auf dem Weg für richtig
halten. Mit einem VPN kann
man zumindest bestimmen,
quasi
es sieht so aus als will er Traffic woanders hin als er wirklich hin will
der will nämlich erstmal zum
Node, zum VPN
Gateway vom Anbieter
und darin ist die Route wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anders wie
beispielsweise zu Blizzard Games Servern
und der VPN Anbieter selbst
wo das dann raus geht kann auch mal eine andere, also
das macht natürlich Sinn
Das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt helfen, aber das kann helfen.
Es gibt extra Gaming VPNs, die damit werben.
Sie haben quasi ganz viele verschiedene Server auf der Welt und können optimierte Routen anbieten.
Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Können optimierte Routen anbieten, beispielsweise zu Gameservern in Korea und solche Geschichten.
Dafür kann das auch ganz sinnig sein.
Verbindung zwischen Surfern, ja gut.
Dafür, mir ging es jetzt um so Sachen wie NordVPN und solche Geschichten.
Dass VPN an sich, ja, zur Einwahl in die Firma Homeoffice mäßig und so sinnvoll ist, ja, das ist klar.
Das ist aber nicht das, was die meisten VPN-Anbieter anbieten.
Ich habe einen Rechner mit Linux und Windows
Kann ich die Festplatte nachträglich noch verschlüsseln?
Ja
Also wenn du Dualboot hast
Das habe ich noch nie gemacht
Ehrlich gesagt
Also was du auf jeden Fall machen kannst ist
Bei Windows
Vollverschlüsselung mit Veracrypt
Würde ich übrigens Bitlocker auch vorziehen
und Linux mit Lux
ich bin mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt
nicht ganz sicher
wie das mit Dual Boot funktioniert
ich würde mal drauf tippen
du musst dann
in den Crab booten
der Crab kann Linux booten
und Windows
und wenn er Windows bootet landet er halt letztendlich
dann erst nochmal auf VeraCrypt Bootloader und musst dann
Passwort eingeben. Das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Also gehen tut das, bin ich mir sehr, sehr sicher, dass das
funktioniert. Gemacht
habe ich das noch nicht. Dual Boot
Linux Windows Rechner
mit jeweils Vollverschlüsselung.
Was du aber machen kannst ist,
du kannst
Windows auf einer SSD installieren,
das finde ich eh besser.
Windows auf einer SSD installieren
und Linux auf der anderen
SSD installieren, jeweils mit Vollverschlüsselung
oder nachträglich Vollverschlüsselung, das ist
dann gar kein Ding. Wobei
ich ehrlich gesagt glaube ich,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich Linux
schon mal nachträglich vollverschlüsselt habe,
ehrlich gesagt. Kein Schimmer, aber gehen
tut das bestimmt.
Und dann kannst du im BIOS
über das Bootmenü einfach auswählen, was du starten willst.
Da brauchst du kein extra Crab. Also das ist
wahrscheinlich die bessere Variante. Eine
SSD für Windows, eine SSD für Linux
und dann einfach im Bootmenü vom
BIOS auswählen, was du starten willst
und die jeweilige Sache für das Betriebssystem verwenden.
Also Lux unter Linux und Veracrypt unter Windows.
Das dürfte wahrscheinlich die einfachste Variante sein.
So sage ich jetzt mal so aus dem Bauch raus.
Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt, ja.
Ja, ja. Das habe ich auch schon gelesen damals.
Ja, für sowas, wie gesagt, Routing-Sachen, die vielleicht vom Provider schlecht sind, kann durchaus was bringen.
Leute, ich hab ein Problem. Ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo.
Wow, wow, wow, Alter, was ist jetzt los?
Ich bin in zwei Minuten wieder da, wobei es könnte auch drei Minuten dauern.
Und Chat, benehmt euch, ich beobachte euch vom Handy aus.
Ich bin gleich, Moment, ich hab doch hier
ein Aff-Klo mittlerweile
So, ich bin gleich wieder am Start
Dann gucken wir, was Trended
auf geht
Und machen einen Reboot
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Musik
So, wieder am Start.
Siegbert fragt, moin Max, zwei Jahre schon kein YouTube-Video mehr.
Kommt irgendwann mal wieder eins?
Womöglich sogar mal kein IT-Content.
Ja, tatsächlich wird es auf jeden Fall wieder geben.
Ich werde nie komplett aufhören mit YouTube.
Hat es geklappt?
Ja, exzellent, exzellent.
Ich werde nie komplett aufhören mit YouTube.
Ich konnte das letzte Jahr.
Das Jahr davor hatte ich einfach irgendwie keinen Bock.
Das letzte Jahr konnte ich nicht. Ich werde auch ein Video zu machen, warum. Ich habe mich ja im Stream schon öfters dazu ausgelassen, weil ich denke, dass das auch ein Thema ist, was viel mehr Leute betrifft, als man eigentlich so denkt.
Weil damit geht ja keiner jetzt irgendwie großartig rum und erzählt das jedem.
Und das ist kein IT-Content.
Und dann habe ich mir noch ein paar andere Sachen aufgeschrieben, wozu ich mich auslassen wollte.
Ich habe hier so ein Textdokument, wozu ich mich mal auslassen wollte.
Zum Beispiel wollte ich mich tatsächlich mal dazu auslassen, über das Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Linux-Videos kommen auf YouTube gerade gut an.
Über N-Shittification wollte ich mich auslassen.
Ja, so ein paar Sachen habe ich mir schon aufgeschrieben.
Und ich habe noch ein langes Textdokument bei mir jetzt hier auf dem anderen Windows Account.
Bin überhaupt nicht mehr afk, wo noch Zeug drin steht.
Warum habe ich den Mini-PC auf?
Achso, habe ich jetzt eigentlich Updates gemacht? Ja, oder?
Ja, ja, habe ich gemacht. Updates, hier Updates.
Jetbrains Toolbox wird geupdatet, aha.
wahrscheinlich 20 Minuten oder so.
So lange, wie es halt braucht.
Yes.
Okay.
So, gibt es ein paar Jetbrains-Updates?
Müssen wir mal schauen.
Ja, gibt es. Hier, tatsächlich.
Zack.
Check for updates, das stimmt überhaupt nicht
Das wurde schon geupdatet
Gab es da nicht mal einen Knopf, update all
Oder bin ich jetzt blöd
Achso hier, update, ach hier ist der Knopf
Ne, ne, ne
Schon eine ganze Weile nichts mehr
Aber das hab ich ja auch verkackt, ne
Ich bin ja so, was so soziale Sachen angeht
Bin ich ja der übelste Kackspast
Ich hätt ja auch mal schreiben können
Was?
Cannot update. Okay, warum?
Äh, ist die Festplatte voll?
Hä? Okay.
Warum?
Was hat der für Probleme?
Cannot update. Fail to extract.
Warum failst du denn zu extracten?
Guck mal, das ist irgendwie kaputt.
Okay, wisst ihr was? Wir machen mal
gut die...
Kann man das irgendwie beenden, das Zeug?
Close.
Alter, Wayland, please!
Ah, hier, quit.
Das wurde einfach nicht...
Toolbox, starten wir das mal neu.
Vielleicht geht's ja dann.
Ich glaube,
wir können die Sound-Lautstärke hier mal ein bisschen runter machen.
Das steht auf 130%. Das ist vielleicht jetzt nicht so
das allerbeste.
Und jetzt nochmal Update.
Unpacking und
und Pause Champ, Pause Champ, Pause Champ,
Pause Champ. Ah, jetzt funktioniert's.
Mit dem Friseur
hab ich ab und zu noch Kontakt, ja.
Es gibt da leider kein Game gerade aktuell.
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass
der Frasier, der hat seinen
Twitch-Channel gelöscht, ne? Der hat sich erst umbenannt
und jetzt gibt's den, glaube ich,
gar nicht mehr.
Gar nicht, warum?
So, jetzt Reboot.
Doch, doch, der hat einen.
Der hat vor mir sogar schon gestreamt auf Twitch.
Im Forza-Crime.
Das aktuelle Forza Horizon soll echt nicht schlecht sein.
Das Ding ist halt,
Ich bin null begeisterungsfähig für irgendwelche Rennspiele.
Gar nicht.
Überhaupt nicht.
Japan Setting.
Ja, das habe ich gelesen.
Und es soll richtig gut gemacht sein.
Also es soll nicht nur richtig gut aussehen, es soll auch vom Game an sich gut aussehen.
Wäre ich gut sein. Aber wie gesagt, Rennspiele
ist gar nichts für mich.
Ich konnte damit nie großartig was
anfangen. Selbst zu Zeiten, ihr wisst ja,
ich bin ein alter Sack, selbst zu Zeiten,
als Need for Speed noch gut war,
konnte ich damit nichts anfangen.
Das war so eines der Mainstream-Rennspiele.
Ne, ne.
Ne.
Konnte ich noch nie was mit anfangen.
Was mir aber aufgefallen ist in letzter Zeit
Irgendwie, man merkt schon, dass ich mittlerweile alter Sack bin
Ich kann viel mehr mit guter Grafik aus alten Spielen anfangen
Wie mit guter Grafik aus neuen Spielen
Ja, also ich kann beispielsweise heute Far Cry 1 spielen
Und mich super freuen, wie gut das für damalige Verhältnisse ausgesehen hat
als dass ich irgendein aktuelles Spiel spiele
und mich freue, wie gut es jetzt aussieht.
Ich weiß, klingt merkwürdig,
ist aber so.
Wie alt bist du mittlerweile? Ich werde dieses Jahr 42.
Old-ge.
Haben wir überhaupt ein Emote für Old?
Wupp, Old?
Ja, ja, aber ich meine
bei mir hier.
Hier meine ich.
Chat, seht ihr irgendein Emote für Old?
Oder bin ich einfach nur blind?
Haben wir hier ein Old-Gear-Emote drin irgendwo?
Ne, oder?
Kein Old-Gear-Emote.
North System.
Dankeschön.
Prime Subscription.
Pog.
Huge Sub.
Excellent, danke für den Sub.
Also ich sehe hier kein Old Emote.
Warum haben wir denn kein Old Emote hier drin?
Was ist denn da los?
Das ist ja richtig...
Wundert mich eigentlich.
So, wisst ihr was geil wäre?
Für dieses Dashboard.
Wenn man hier oben suchen könnte.
Das Problem ist nur.
Ich benutze das ja seit 5 Jahren oder so
Das habe ich irgendwann mal selbst gebastelt
Das Problem ist nur
Guck mal
Die Suche ist broken
Das ist eine
View 1 Anwendung oder sowas
Das ist uralt
Und
Ich konnte mich bisher noch nicht dazu
Durchringen mit, keine Ahnung, 8 Jahren
Oder wie lange auch immer ich jetzt auf Twitch bin
Keine Ahnung
acht Jahre alte Anwendung
nochmal anzufassen.
Das heißt, die Suche ist kaputt und die Suche wird für immer kaputt sein.
Ne, wir haben wirklich kein Emote für Old.
Na ja, gut.
Rewrite. Ja, ganz, ganz
bestimmt.
Das könnte, ich bin mir relativ
sicher, das könnte die KI, weil man
muss sagen, der Source-Code ist ja nicht sonderlich
kompliziert, guck mal hier
Web-Application
11, by the way
Web-Application 11
www
gut
ne
Wo habe ich denn überhaupt meine Anwendung hier liegen?
Chatge, WPF-App wird es nicht sein
Views, ne
Wo ist dann überhaupt
www-Route
müsste es sein, oder?
Habe ich hier überhaupt einen gescheiten Editor?
Also, Bessel, your notepad, just once
Roboto, Signal A
View, ja, ja, doch, doch
Hier
Search
Ja, da müsste man sich jetzt mal
durchkämpfen
Lib
Sag mal, kann das Content
Ne, das sind die Bilder
Sag mal, kann das sein
Ach, hier gibt es ein JavaScript.
Und hier ist es wahrscheinlich drin.
Alter.
Ja, vielleicht fixen wir das tatsächlich irgendwann mal.
Weil so eine Suche wäre echt nicht verkehrt.
Ich weiß, wahrscheinlich wird KI das...
Okay, also ich habe hier kein Cloud-Login.
Aber wir können mal...
Wir fragen mal die China-KI.
Ich kann auch Kimi fragen.
Mal gucken, was die China-KI dazu sagt.
GLM 4.7.
Moment.
Konnte man da nicht mal GLM 5 oder so auswählen?
Kann es sein, dass die GLM 5
Alter, die China-Chinesen, was ist da los?
Nee, Open Code ist nicht richtig konfiguriert
Was ist mit den China-Chinesen los?
Ich will 5.1 haben
Ja, dann benutze ich keinen China-Chinesen-Model
Okay, Kimi
Hat Kimi
ein
die neuesten Models
kostenlos zum benutzen?
Woher weiß ich? Ah hier, Kimi
Car Thinking.
Das wollen wir haben, oder?
Oder?
Oder Chat? Ich hab das noch nie verwendet.
Hier über dem Browser.
Wollen wir das haben?
Das wollen wir haben.
Wenn ich
in der Suche
Suche
geht.
Oh ne.
Ich will kein File uploaden.
Paste content exceeds.
Okay, wisst ihr was? Lack mich, Chat, gebt bitte.
Wenn ich
in der Suche suche,
dann geht's kaputt
mit folgender
Fehlermeldung.
Quen. Quen können wir auch ausprobieren.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Warte mal. Ich muss mal die
Fehlermeldung
nochmal.
Weil das ist immer nicht schlecht.
Wenn die ein bisschen Kontext haben.
Hier der
js source code
So
Der Stacktrace
Deutet darauf hin
Da der Fehler beim Tickensurge ist, ist wahrscheinlich
Dein computed property
Okay, das kann durchaus sein, ja
This items enthält
Undefined, möglich
Okay, chatgpt
Is useless
Dann kopieren wir das nochmal.
Guck mal bei den...
Sind das auch China-Chinesen?
Nee, war
Quenlich was Europäisches?
Oder war das Minimax?
Okay, es scheint was
Chinesisches zu sein.
Input is limited.
Tja, keine Chance, Leute.
Wir wissen es nicht.
Okay, komm, wir pasten ihm noch
Wir pasten ihm noch das HTML rein
Ach, Mistral war das, genau
Der Fehler entsteht häufig
Ja, ach
Okay, keine Ahnung mit ChatGPT.
Das habe ich doch schon.
ChatGPT schreibt wieder einen halben Roman.
Wow, MonkaS, Alter.
Ja, dann werden wir das jetzt nicht gefixt kriegen auf die Schnelle.
Ich könnte mir ja hier einen gescheiten Editor installieren und mal selbst reingucken, weil ich wette mit euch,
das ist nicht sonderlich kompliziert zu fixen, was ich damals fabriziert habe.
Aber egal, das machen wir jetzt heute nicht.
Kein Bock drauf.
Wie läuft es eigentlich im neuen Job?
Naja, so neu ist es jetzt ja
Ich meine, du schreibst zwar nach wie vor, aber so neu
Das ist jetzt nicht der neue, das ist der Job mittlerweile
Ich meine, ich bin seit über drei Jahren jetzt da
Also man könnte sagen, mittlerweile habe ich mich eingewöhnt
Und ich denke überhaupt nicht mehr an den alten Job
Und ansonsten finde ich es da richtig nice
Ich lobe die ja tatsächlich auch öfters mal im Stream
Obwohl ich weiß, dass mein Chef nicht zuguckt
Er kennt meinen Channel nicht
Ist mir auch lieber, wenn möglichst wenige Leute von der Arbeit zugucken
Dann kann ich auch mal ein bisschen ablästern
Und keiner fühlt sich irgendwie
Ist er irgendwie angepisst oder so
Es ist deutlich anders
Ja, es ist deutlich
Wie soll man das nennen?
Deutlich weniger planlos
als beim alten Job. Also es gibt,
wie gesagt, es gibt halt super krass
viel Bürokratie bei uns.
Ist halt so.
Nur, also zum Beispiel, ich nehme mal
ein Beispiel, was jetzt
viel besser ist, was aber halt auch richtig krass Bürokratie
ist. Und zwar,
im alten Job, da kam das
ab und zu mal vor, dass irgendjemand
gesagt hat, ah, wir brauchen da einen neuen Server.
Aber das ist geheim, nicht
weitererzählen. Da laufen irgendwelche
auswertung sachen drauf wo wir nicht wissen wollen dass das hier wo wir nicht wissen also
wurde es nicht jeder wissen soll und da und am ende hat es dann server da stehen und für keiner
richtig zuständig ist das gibt es beim neuen job nicht bei mir jetzt wo ich bin bei der versicherung
ist es so bevor ein sie wenn dann nicht die zuständigkeiten geklärt sind wird das ding
nicht in produktion aufgebaut der schweigen live genommen du hast immer einen ansprechpartner für
mindestens zwei sachen einmal für die technische seite den server selbst also
linux was drauf läuft und so war es
das wäre es gewesen wäre das war irgendwelche reporting sachen für den
vorstand so und dann das wollte ich jetzt sagen
pack jetzt habe ich ablenken lassen
ja du hast immer immer einen der sich damit aus also auskennt einmal von
technischer seite und dann hast du auch immer einen festen ansprechpartner für
was dafür eine anwendung drauf läuft was praktisch ist weil das ist das was sie
bei mir im alten job auch nicht richtig gecheckt haben nur weil du den server
installiert hast und vielleicht eine anwendung drauf scp tast wobei es da auch
bessere varianten geben sollte aber sagen wir mal du hast du aufgebaut und
irgendwie irgendein file darauf scp das heißt noch lange nicht dass du was dazu
du sagen kannst, was los ist,
wenn die Anwendung crasht.
Oder wenn die Anwendung Probleme hat.
Das war bei mir im alten Job so.
Irgendwelche Java-Anwendungen
haben irgendwelche Dinger gemacht. Die Leute
standen bei mir auf der Mart und haben gesagt,
Max, was ist denn da los? Und ich sagte, keine Ahnung.
Wo soll ich wissen,
warum sich das Ding jetzt verschluckt?
Die Fehlermeldung ist 5 Seiten Java
Stacktrace mit
irgendwelchem Zeug, wovon ich keine Ahnung habe.
Woher soll ich das wissen?
Wir mussten, nur mal zum Beispiel, Beispiel, Beispiel vom alten Job, ne?
Also, sowas, also machen wir mal, machen wir mal wirklich ein negatives Beispiel vom alten Job, was es so im Neuen nicht gegeben hätte.
Ja, hier, Java, die Compiler.
Also, wir hatten mal das Problem, dass eine Anwendung, eine Java-Anwendung, nicht über den Proxy ins Internet ist.
Obwohl wir die Startargumente
Fragt mich jetzt nicht wie das genau geht
Da musste irgendwie eine kryptische
Java
Ops
Proxy, musste irgendwas
Irgendwas kryptisches
Musste da setzen
Hier irgendwelche Dinger und so
So zumindest
Haben wir das gesetzt
Und der Server
Wollte einfach nicht über den
Proxy ins Internet
beziehungsweise halt
HTTP über einen Proxy machen.
Und es gab keinen Ansprechpartner
für die Anwendung.
Beziehungsweise der Ansprechpartner für die Anwendung war weg.
So, und was wir damals gemacht haben ist,
wir haben uns den Java
Decompiler geholt.
Keine Ahnung, ob das der war. Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Wir haben uns den Java Decompiler
geholt und haben uns angeguckt,
wo in dem Jar
Proxy-Sachen
gesetzt werden.
Und sind dann irgendwo drauf gekommen, ich glaube das wurde aus irgendeiner Environment Variable eingelesen und da hat sich irgendwie verschrieben.
Es hieß nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, es hieß dann nicht HTTP Proxy oder so, sondern keine Ahnung, HTTPS Proxy oder irgendwie sowas.
Und da musste man die Java Anwendung decompilen, um zu gucken, was das Problem ist.
Und ganz ehrlich, das ist ja schön und gut, dass ich mich ein bisschen für Programmieren interessiere und dass wir andere Leute haben auch, die ganz gerne über den Tellerrand gucken.
Aber das sollte sicherlich nicht der Job sein, desjenigen, der sich administrativ um die Linux-Seite von dem Server kümmert.
Da sollte es jemanden geben, der Ahnung von der Anwendung hat.
So, und das gab es in dem Fall bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber nicht.
Da mussten wir das Ding decompilen und rumwurschteln.
Guck mal, man kann sogar Maus grad scrollen hier drin, das wusste ich gar nicht.
So, und bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber, also bei meinem jetzigen Arbeitgeber,
neu heißt ja nicht, also wie gesagt, ich bin seit drei Jahren schon da.
Bei meinem jetzigen Arbeitgeber ist es so, du guckst einfach nach,
also zum Beispiel, du bist früh da um 7.30 Uhr,
dich ruft irgendeiner an, also die gucken dann, also meistens läuft das so, da können wir schon mal anders anfangen.
Also, Service XY gibt den Geist auf, dann kann man bei uns nachgucken in so einer zentralen Datenbank,
wer ist denn zuständig für das System auf Anwendungsebene, wer ist denn zuständig für das System auf Linux-Ebene
und dann
guckst du,
wer ist denn schon da von dem Team
und rufst den an oder guckst,
wer hat denn
Rufbereitschaft, wenn es außerhalb der normalen Zeiten
ist oder sowas. Also du kannst immer nachgucken.
Und ich kann auch nachgucken,
wenn dann trotzdem einer bei mir anruft
und sagt,
Max, der Server geht nicht. Ich gucke mir das an
und sage, ey, guck mal, die Java-Anwendung
crasht, Festplatte
ist genug da, Arbeitsspeicher ist genug da,
das sieht mir jetzt auch nicht nach irgendwelchen Permissions
aus, keine Ahnung, lass uns doch
mal jemand anrufen, der Ahnung von der Anwendung hat.
Dann kannst du ganz genau nachgucken,
wer, also namentlich,
Ahnung von der Anwendung hat
und wenn du den anrufst, und das kommt
auch öfters vor, also nur weil der da steht,
heißt das nicht automatisch, dass der wahnsinnig Plan
davon hätte, ja? Also es kommt auch manchmal
vor, dass du den Anwendungsverantwortlichen
anrufst und er sagt,
oh ja, ich hab die Anwendung vor drei Jahren
übernommen, eigentlich habe ich da gar keine Ahnung
von. Aber der Riesenvorteil
jetzt, zudem wie es beim alten
Arbeitgeber war, ist, dass der dann sagt,
ich gucke mir das mal an
oder ich suche mir auch mal jemanden, der davon Ahnung hat.
Du musst als Admin nicht rumrennen
und auf gut Glück 50
Leute anrufen, bis mal einer davon Ahnung hat.
Also das ist wirklich gut.
Auf der anderen Seite, die Schattenseite
davon ist, wir haben so ultra
viel Bürokratie, Alter, das ist nicht normal.
Hat dein Inhouse-Praktikum mittlerweile stattgefunden?
Ne, wir haben noch gar keinen Termin dazu ausgemacht.
Ich hatte andere Probleme.
So.
Mal kurz was schreiben.
Gut, bin am Start.
Max, kaufst du SpaceX Aktien?
Wieso sollte man das jetzt machen?
Ist das ein sicherer Tipp, den mir der Twitch-Chat nennt?
Chat?
Chat, was sagt ihr?
SpaceX Aktien kaufen.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz gucken hier.
Wenn der Twitch Chat mir das empfiehlt,
kann das eigentlich gar nicht in die Hose gehen.
Oder?
Okay.
SpaceX.
Die finde ich gar nicht
bei Scalable.
Nach was muss ich
da suchen?
Die haben bald Börsengang.
Ach so.
By the way,
ich habe meine Scalable App gerade kaputt gemacht
mit einer Suche danach.
die hängt jetzt weg
so jetzt geht es wieder wohl gestartet
Okay
Ich verfolge das nicht
Ich habe mein World ETF und den Rest interessiert mich nicht
So, dann schauen wir doch mal
Was trendet denn auf GitHub so?
Weekly
Fangen wir mit Go an, warum nicht?
Ne, ne Leute, wir fangen nicht mit Gau an
Wir fangen mit Kobol an
Weil, ich hab ein Video gefunden
Achso, vorhin hat doch irgendjemand ein Video gepostet
Und gemeint, wär das nicht was für ein Stream
Lass mal kurz gucken
Sollte man da nicht eine Vorschau anzeigen?
Geil
Das ist direkt im Stream auf
Ey, das hab ich
Das hab ich sogar schon aufgemacht
Das hab ich auch empfohlen bekommen
Lustig
Das hab ich hier, guck mal
Siehste, da ist es
Das wollte ich mir vielleicht nachher auch angucken
Aber wisst ihr, warum wir nach Kobol gucken müssen?
Ich hab dieses Video hier in den Empfehlungen gehabt
Ein FPS in Kobol programmieren
Das müssen wir uns nachher mal angucken
Ich wusste gar nicht
Dass du mit Kobol überhaupt
Dass Kobol in irgendeiner Art und Weise
Irgendeine
Pixelzeile
einen api hat aber gut wahrscheinlich kannst du kannst du betriebssystem calls machen
okay dann gucken wir doch mal was weekly trendet also was denn trivi hatte trivi
nicht auch vor nicht allzu langer zeit irgendeine supply chain attacke war da nicht was erinnere
mich so dunkel. Hier, Trivi, Supply Chain
Angriff führt zu Kompromittierung in
in, in was? Postchamp?
In
Deutschland.
Übrigens,
was ich noch gar nicht erzählt habe,
Bevor wir uns die Trends angucken.
Diese Woche war echt anstrengend.
Ich war am Dienstag
in Hannover.
Hier.
Da war ich.
Bei Iron Maiden in Hannover.
Am 2.6.
Und
ich bin mit einem
Kollege hingefahren.
Und Leute, das war echt anstrengend.
Ich bin um 12 los
von Hanau aus.
Die leben noch, ja, da sind Opas, die sind auch schon
70 plus.
Und ich bin
um 12 los
und wir sind ja am gleichen
Tag nach Hannover hingefahren
und wieder zurück.
Und ich war dann um 3.45
oder so im Bett.
Das habe ich gemerkt. Das habe ich richtig gemerkt.
Ich bin das da immer gewohnt.
So, und
am Mittwoch,
einen Tag danach,
war ich da noch
auf dem
GP-Morgenlauf in Frankfurt.
Nach nur
ein paar Stunden Schlaf. Da war ich echt
im Arsch danach.
Ich habe auch ein Foto mit Minions gemacht
Kann ich euch aber nicht zeigen
Im Ziel konnte man Fotos mit Minions machen
Warum auch immer
Weil die haben Werbung für irgendeinen neuen Film gemacht
Essen-Show geht nicht
Essen-Show ist broken
Ja, ich habe schon ordentlich gepennt
Essen-Shower ist broken
Oh, die Fatz geht noch
Ja
Da bin ich geflitzt hier
Aber langsam
Ich bin mit dem Kollege gelaufen
Also
Ich kann euch meine Zeit sagen
Die war nicht sonderlich
Sonderlich schnell
Ich bin mit dem Collage gelaufen
Und ich hatte
Ne, ich sag euch meine Zeit nicht
Can't wait
Deswegen
Lul HD
Gut
Chat, wir müssen ja noch gucken
Ich kann mal was checken
Wir müssen ja noch gucken, was trendet auf GitHub
Waren wir gleich
Wo habe ich denn den Chat?
Ich habe jetzt gerade das Fenster falsch angeklickt
MonkaS
Warum habe ich jetzt das Fenster nicht
Hier, okay, passt
Alles klar.
So, also was trennt ihr denn auf GitHub?
Hast du den Lego-Skandal mitbekommen?
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Wieso?
Was ist da schon wieder los?
Also Trivi.
Trivi, genau, da wollte ich keine Ahnung.
Die hatten ja auch irgendwann mal Supply Chain Attacke vor einem halben Jahr oder so.
Open Telemetry Go.
Wisst ihr, was mich interessiert?
Das verwende ich öfters.
Also jetzt nicht Open Telemetry Go direkt, sondern das Prometheus, das Go Prometheus SDK.
Ob die mittlerweile...
Wie hieß der Kram nochmal? Das wollte ich gerade mal suchen bei GitHub.
es gibt die
für Metriken, gibt es diese Prometheus
Specification
und dann Open Metrix
heißt das, heißt das Open Metrix
Format
ja genau
Go Prometheus
ob die das mittlerweile unterstützen
dass man nämlich unit annotations machen kann
das muss ich gerade mal gucken weil
Weil...
Das ist die offizielle Go-Library.
Und die haben es ewig nicht hingekriegt, dass man Unit-Annotations machen kann.
Gucken, ob sie das mittlerweile geschafft haben.
Hier, Matrix Unit Support.
Warum ist das 2019?
Vielleicht wurde das jetzt erst geschlossen, hä?
Completed.
Ach ja, okay.
Nach sieben Jahren haben sie es jetzt geschafft anscheinend.
Wir haben Matrix Support endlich drin.
Nach sieben Jahren, Alter.
Nice.
Was ein Geschäft hat Leute betrogen und wurde verklagt.
Ja gut, bei den Amis verklagt ja gefühlt jeder eh jeden.
Die Besitzer sind aber Mormonen.
Was?
Und haben die gesamte Polizei in Utah auf die Kläger gehetzt, weil die auch alle bei Mormonen sind.
Das ist quasi so eine Art Clan wie bei uns in Berlin.
Nur das ist dann ein Mormonen-Kanal alles.
Also die Mormonen, nicht das mit den Aliens, die Aliens kommen vorbei und holen die Leute ab.
Ne, das ist Scientology, glaube ich. Keine Ahnung.
So, also, was trendet denn, was trendet denn auf GitHub?
Trivi, OpenTelemetry, Go, PentAI, Kubernetes trendet.
Warum hat denn ausgerechnet Kubernetes die Woche so viel abgekriegt?
Hatten die eine neue Version?
dann trennt es einfach mal so wieder aber auch zu recht mittlerweile muss man muss man ja gar
nicht sagen also muss man muss den satz muss ich anders anfangen ich hatte letztens mit einem aus
unserem projekt gespräch zu über kubernetes und cloud functions und solche geschichten und da
habe ich als erstes gesagt ja also kubernetes ist quasi in den container orchestrator kannst
dir vorstellen wie quasi so einen docker cluster und dann ist mir eingefallen eigentlich macht es
keinen sinn zu sagen kubernetes ist eines der container orchestrator es gibt neben kubernetes
nichts anderes mehr also es mag sicherlich die ein oder anderen versuche geben aber von
Von der Verbreitung her ist es Kubernetes und sonst nix.
Nix.
Es gibt nix anderes in der Richtung.
Was dann nennenswerte Konkurrenz wäre.
Ach, Kumanetis hat einen Geburtstag.
Ja, ja.
Vercel, Vercel ist ein Anbieter
für so
Serverless-Dinger.
Das sind auch die,
wo das Weltentwickler arbeitet.
Ja.
Da kannst du deine Node.js Anwendungen hosten
und sowas. Habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Scheint aber wohl ganz
gut zu sein. Das ist jetzt einfach nur geraten.
Ich habe das noch nie verwendet. Scheint aber wohl ganz
gut zu sein, weil sich das seit ein paar
letzten 2-3
Jahre eigentlich immer weiter festsetzt.
Und es ist meistens ein Zeichen
dafür, dass das Produkt nicht ganz beschissen sein kann.
Früher gab es auch Netlify.
Von dem höre ich jetzt aber immer weniger.
Ich höre eigentlich nur was von Wurstel.
Docker Swarm.
Ja, aber Docker Swarm gibt es ja schon länger als Kubernetes.
Aber das ist bei weitem nicht so umfangreich.
Und vor allem, und das ist ja das, worum es mir hauptsächlich ging,
nicht mal ansatzweise nennenswert verbreitet im Vergleich zu Kubernetes.
olama trendet
selbsthause server website monitoring tool und o und m tool chat was ist ein o und m tool
hat jemand eine ahnung
Äh, OpenShift ist doch auch Kubernetes, oder?
Der Chat, Alter.
Observability und Monitoring.
Okay, das ist in der Tat interessant.
Ich bin ja immer noch auf der Suche
Nach einem Monitoring System
Was mich nicht abfuckt
Okay, da bin ich mal gespannt, zeigt mal her
Lass erstmal gucken, ob es gevibecoded ist
Ist es gevibecoded?
Ich sehe jetzt hier erstmal keinen Cloud
Oder Codex oder sonst was
Das heißt aber nichts
Wir checken trotzdem mal, ob es vibecoded ist
Utils
HTTP Go
Das, das, das
So ewig lange
Comments davor haben immer so
Einen leichten Vibe-Coding-Vibe
Aber das hier sieht nicht unbedingt
Das sieht nicht unbedingt
Auf den ersten Blick
Krass Vibe-Coded aus
Okay, was ist das denn?
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal ein bisschen
ein bisschen angucken. Also
NetzH
Monitoring
Self-hosted Lineware-Servers, Website-Monitoring
und Observability
und Matrix-Tool
Monitoring-Tool
Gibt, okay, China
China-Chinesen
User Guide, Englisch
Gibt es da vielleicht von der Oberfläche
auch ein paar Screenshots
Sehr gut
Was bin ich hier sehend
Ein Dashboard
Ein bisschen mehr Infos wären schon ganz nice
Ja
One Click Installation, Preview
Gibt es da eine Demo oder so, um die man sich...
I-O-N-G?
Was?
Welche Seite mache ich jetzt hier gerade auf?
Chat?
Ah, das ist quasi so ein
Uptime, Uptime, China-Chinesen-Uptime-Dashboard.
Flashbang.
Raspberry Pi 5
Router.
Status
Process
Okay, und
und
Ach, das hier ist der User Guide
Oder was?
Hat das Ding
Install, okay, das hat einen eigenen Agent
Und was kann der
Standardmäßig so?
Was kann der Agent
Standardmäßig so abfragen?
Oder was hat das so für Standard
Standard-Metrix und Sachen
drin.
Ah, das ist
ein bisschen minimalistisch hier.
Warum MCP?
Kann man sein
Monitoring mit seiner KI verbinden?
Run a command.
Okay.
Oh ja.
Ich probiere ja gerne solche Dinge aus
Ich bookmark mir das mal
Ich glaube nicht, dass es was ist
Was daheim jetzt irgendwie mein Zabbix ablösen wird
Bisschen mehr Screenshots wäre immer ganz nice
Oder findet ihr das nicht auch?
Screenshots sagen oftmals mehr als tausend Seiten Docs
Interesting.
Okay, das Bookmark
ich mir mal.
Das löschen wir mal.
Haben wir hier eigentlich für Dinge alles gespeichert?
Delta, das habe ich doch schon installiert.
Das brauchen wir mal. Delete Bookmark.
Delete Bookmark.
1000 Sachen hier.
So, okay.
Gucken wir mal weiter.
AI.
Prometheus.
Go.
AI.
Loki.
Jetzt sehen wir mal wieder heute mal ein paar Sachen, die ich kenne.
Dold.
Da habe ich letztens ein Video zu gesehen.
Da hat irgendjemand gesagt,
Das ist ein SQL-Git oder irgendwie sowas
Das Video habe ich aber nicht geguckt
Habe ich nur das Intro, habe ich mir gedacht, okay, whatever
Irgendwas ganz hart abgedrehtes Pfeil fährt
Also du kannst deine Datenbank damit branchen und sowas
Scheint saubelieb zu sein
Das ist mir aber zu high IQ hier, wenn ich da schon drüber scrolle
Okay, man kann bestehende Datenbanken verwenden
Du kannst da Branches anlegen
In deiner Datenbank, so was ganz abgedrehtes Zeug
Wie gesagt, ich hab nur ganz kurz
Das Intro da geguckt, Terraform trendet
Chat
Wie ist es bei euch?
Seid ihr noch auf Terraform? Seid ihr auf OpenTofu?
Bleibt ihr auf Terraform?
Wollt ihr auf OpenTofu wechseln?
Also bei mir auf der Arbeit ist es mittlerweile so
Terraform ist komplett weg
Das ist nur noch Open Tofu überall.
Also falls ihr das überhaupt verwendet.
Terraform ist teilweise richtiger Abwack, ja.
Was mich auch richtig nervt in Terraform ist, macht man ein If in Terraform.
Das geht gar nicht so ohne weiteres.
Also du kannst hier diese Schreibweise machen, aber so einen richtigen If-Block hier.
Da musste, da musste
Go Templates
und so komisches, komisches Zeug verwenden
Guck, das kannst du machen, das ist das, was ich gemeint habe
Aber es gibt keinen richtigen If-Block
Man kann wohl irgendwie
das mit, mit, mit Templates machen
oder so, glaube ich zumindest
Aber
ist schon, ist schon eklig
Ja, wir haben auch, außer das haben die da gar keine Beispiele für.
Ah ja, mit Go-Templates und so, das funzt schon.
Aber ich find's trotzdem eklig, dass da kein...
Warum gibt's da kein normales if?
Keine normale if-Syntax in Terraform.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Moin.
Ja.
Was sind deine Gründe für Open Tofu gegen Terraform?
Das Einzige, was ich davon mitgekriegt habe, ist,
dass Terraform vor, boah, da weiß ich nicht, zwei Jahren oder so,
irgendwas an ihren Lizenzbedingungen geändert hat,
woraufhin dann Open Tofu entstanden ist,
Open Tofu auch ziemlich so Traction aufgenommen hat
und jetzt total viele Open Tofu umgeschwenkt sind.
Ob die Lizenzbedingungen wirklich problematisch sind oder so,
weiß ich überhaupt nicht.
Keine Ahnung, ob das überhaupt relevant ist.
Habe ich mich nie mit beschäftigt, großartig
Kaddi trendet, Kaddi ist top
Ein HTTP
123 Webserver
Kaddi ist nice
Also ich würde
Sagen wir mal so
Ich ziehe Nginx vor
Außer für den Fall
Der Fälle, wo es ganz
simple Web-Server,
also Static-Webseiten
oder ein simpler
Einzeiler-Reverse-Proxy ist
mit Let's Encrypt, dann ist
Cudi kaum zu schlagen. Für Cudi
brauchst du eine Zeile, also
wenn das ein Public-Server im Internet ist,
brauchst du eine Zeile,
es funktioniert inklusive Let's Encrypt-Zertifikat.
Also das ist
ungeschlagen von der Einfachheit
halber her.
Für alles bisschen Komplexere ziehe ich
Nginx vor. Aber für solche
einfachen dinge ist kann das beste was es gibt etwas ist eurer meinung nach
da machen wir mal eine umfrage wir machen mal eine umfrage was ist
eurer meinung nach der web server mit der hässlichsten config syntax also
apache lassen wir mal außen vor weil ich glaube er kommt bei patch über und wir
kann sagen, Apache ist halt echt hässlich.
Okay.
Wer hat die
hässlichste
Webserver-Config? Oder was?
Was hat die hässlichste Webserver-Config?
Apache, Nginx,
Traffic,
Aproxy
auch nochmal rein.
Traffic ist richtig eklig.
Wir machen nur Linux, Leute. Nur Linux.
Nicht IES. IES ist klar, dass
IES gewinnt.
Und...
Kadi.
Also ich habe jetzt Apache, Nginx, Traffic, HA, Proxy, Kadi.
Habe ich schon irgendwas vergessen?
Verbreitet es?
Ich glaube nicht.
Egal.
Mehr kann ich hier nicht eintippen.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Also, meiner Meinung nach, Apache gefolgt von Traffic.
Ja, sehe ich genauso.
Apache gefolgt von Traffic. So ist es bei mir auch.
Das hat zwar eine Minute laufen.
Ich denke mal, so viele Leute können da gar nicht abstimmen, weil man muss sie erst mal verwendet haben.
EVCC trendet.
Ich habe letztens was gelesen, dass
Ich glaube VW
VW hat ihre API
Abgeschafft, glaube ich
War da nicht irgendwas
VW
Hier
VW kappt die API Änderung
VW kappt mit API Änderung
Besitzern Zugriff auf die eigene Fahrzeugdaten
Asten, Alter
Apache hat gewonnen
Okay, ja, das verstehe ich
Übrigens, genau so denke ich mir das auch
Apache auf 1, Traffic auf 2
Die Traffic-Config ist auch eklig, wenn man die von Hand machen muss
Die Daten, die zuvor öffentlich im Netz erreichbar waren
Ja, ich glaube, das ging ganz ohne Token, ne?
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt das wiederum nicht verstehe.
Könnt ihr nicht einfach eine API anbieten, wo du dich mit irgendeinem Token authentifizieren musst und gut ist?
Bei, ups, äh, bei Fiat ist es ja auch so.
Bei Fiat musst du dich anmelden, um die API, also brauchst du einen Token, um die API zu benutzen.
Und dann ist gut. Wobei Fiat ja überhaupt keine Public-API hat, ne?
Hat Fiat mittlerweile eine Public-API? Ich glaube nicht.
Äh, was ist das?
Ich glaube nicht, dass es...
Ich glaube, das ist Blödsinn.
Das ist von irgendeinem Drittanbieter.
Ach, Banking, okay.
Keine Ahnung, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Ja, und die haben das jetzt irgendwie abgeschaltet bei VW.
Was halt richtig kacke ist für Leute,
die so Sachen wie EVCC verwenden,
zum Laden von ihren Autos.
Autos.
EVCC an sich ein richtig geiles
Projekt. Also wenn ich
eine Solaranlage hätte,
dann hätte ich
auch EVCC laufen.
Kannst dann Autoladen
passend zur Sonneneinstrahlung
und sowas. Ein richtig geiles Projekt.
Und leider jetzt nicht mehr so richtig möglich mit
VW Autos. Also es ist immer noch
teilweise möglich.
Ja, weil du kannst ja deine Wallbox nach wie vor
steuern und du hast dein Solarpanel
in der Heimautomatisierung. Das geht schon.
Aber wenn du Infos vom Auto haben möchtest, zum Beispiel Akkustand oder sowas, dann geht das nicht richtig.
Ist schon ein bisschen doof.
Ich habe keinen Balkon.
Wo soll ich ein Balkonkraftwerk dran machen, wenn ich keinen Balkon habe?
Gucken wir mal, ob da VW noch drin steht.
voll volkswagen muss man so oder wo die amis an volkswerken volkswerken
Einfach balkon ans haus bauen du meinst ich soll den balkon von aliexpress bestellen
und warum aber aliexpress gucken ob man am balkon bestellen kann
Alter, ich trau mich immer nicht alle...
Guckt euch diese Webseite an.
Jetzt mal seriously.
Wenn du nicht wüsstest, dass das eine legit Seite ist,
würdest du doch jetzt erstmal denken,
das ist übelster Scam, oder?
Und was zum Teufel passiert?
Ich will es...
Ich klicke da nicht drauf jetzt.
Ich klicke da jetzt nicht drauf.
Was ist...
WTF?
Gesichtslifting.
Balkon.
Man kann sich den Balkon bestellen.
Für 5,49 Euro.
Ach so.
Ein Schattennetz kann man sich bestellen.
Wir sortieren mal.
Wir sortieren mal nach.
Geht das überhaupt hier?
Preis.
Okay.
Teuer.
Ich will es teuer haben.
Elektrisch.
Da.
So ist es hier.
Bam.
Elektrischer Gartenpavillon.
Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Gefängnis oder so, oder?
Ein elektrischer Gartenpavillon.
Liefern die auch nach Deutschland?
Versand 368 Euro.
Das erscheint ja noch relativ günstig dafür zu sein.
Hat es...
Es hat keine Bewertung.
Das ist doch ein Photoshoptes Bild, oder?
Was ist daran elektrisch?
Wahrscheinlich die Türen?
Ich hätte jetzt vermutet, es hat elektrische Türen.
Oder auch nicht.
Das Licht ist elektrisch.
Solaraufwand.
Man sieht ja nichts. Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ansonsten gibt es nur Balkonmöbel.
Kein Balkon.
Hey Leute, leider kann man sich kein Balkon bestellen
auf AliExpress.
Ich habe ja eigentlich gedacht,
die liefern auch gleich die Chinesen mit,
die einem dann den Balkon ans Haus
kleben wahrscheinlich.
Sieht nicht so aus.
Wobei ich hab letztens was gelesen auf einer Newsseite.
Und zwar, dass immer weniger Chinesen bereit sind, irgendwelche menschenunwürdige Jobs zu erledigen.
Denen geht es jetzt auch langsam zu gut.
Und da ist jetzt wohl der neueste Trend.
Man kratzt sich ein paar Nordkoreaner über die Grenze.
Die dürfen dann die menschenverachtenden Jobs machen.
Also wahrscheinlich, früher wären da Chinesen geliefert worden, um dir den Balkon dran zu pappen.
Heute würden sie dir wahrscheinlich Nordkoreaner liefern, die dir den Balkon dran pappen.
Farbe 3,3 Meter. Ja, das ist AliExpress.
Ganz ehrlich, bei AliExpress kannst du eigentlich nicht wirklich auf irgendwas was geben.
Guck mal, kostenloser Versand
krieg ich
so ein paar billig China-Dinger.
Die AliExpress-Verpflichtung.
Dieses Produkt kann nicht an ihre Adresse
verwendet werden. Hä?
Wie?
Hier steht vorher,
guck mal,
hier steht lokal in Deutschland,
kann nicht an ihre Adresse
versendet werden. Okay.
Obviously.
Wollen wir mal gucken, was eine RTX 5090
kostet bei AliExpress.
Okay, die sind
sogar bei den China-Chinesen teuer.
Okay, Preis. Preis. Wir gucken mal, was die
billigste Grafikkarte ist.
What the fuck? Alter!
Alter!
Äh.
Warum ist 40 Euro nicht vor
4000 Euro.
Man weiß es nicht.
Desktop-Wasserkühlung.
Da ist angeblich eine 5090
drin, das klaut.
Das ist
beschiss, Leute.
Der ganze PC
ist deutlich
günstiger als eine Grafikkarte.
Im Leben ist da keine 5090 drin
Das sind bestimmt KI Bilder oder?
Ja ja ja auf jeden Fall
Guck mal das sind KI generierte Bilder
Den PC gibt es überhaupt nicht
Guck mal mit nem Alienware Logo
600 Euro Versand
Aber es wäre immer noch günstig für ne Grafikkarte
Für ne 5090
Das ist Scam Leute
Eieiei
We maintain high standards of excellence
Er soll Hardware-Deals mal im Video zu machen
Guck mal, was die für Bewertungen haben
Was die sonst noch so haben
Da kannst du
Moment, du kannst dir sogar irgendeinen kleinen Transporter da kaufen
Oh, eine fucking Luxusjacht
Oh, kurzem angesehen
Okay, Leute, jetzt ist es raus
Luxusjacht
Auf dem Weg schon
Luxusjacht für 16.000 Euro
Klingt legit, oder?
Die wird dann zu dir gefahren direkt
617 Euro Versand
Klingt komplett legit
Die ist bestimmt nicht mal zugelassen
Die darf wahrscheinlich in Deutschland nicht mal schwimmen
Okay, Chat, jetzt die Frage
Ist es ein KI-Video oder nicht?
Aber ich muss mal sagen, sonderlich
Luxus sieht das Ding jetzt nicht aus
Das sieht so
Auf Luxus gemacht aus
Das sieht richtig hässlich aus, ne?
Und wisst ihr, was ich auch witzig finde?
Fehlt da nicht das Display oder so?
Was ich auch witzig finde,
so irgendwie, was für einen Motor und Antrieb
und so kriegt man überhaupt nicht gezeigt.
Man kriegt nur diesen Kram hier gezeigt.
Du musst selber rudern, ja.
Oh, guck mal, das gibt es auch noch in verschiedenen...
In verschiedenen Farben.
Die alle das gleiche kosten.
Okay.
Das Ding sieht richtig hässlich aus, ne?
Guck mal, wie klein das ist.
Also, Luxusjacht würde ich es jetzt nicht unbedingt nennen.
Und außerdem, das fällt doch bei der ersten Gelegenheit um.
Was es nicht alles bei den China-Chinesen zu kaufen gibt.
Flugzeug.
Ach ne, ne Drohne.
Okay.
Guck mal, ein Elektroauto.
Ein Elektroauto für 2600 Euro.
Darf man bestimmt in Deutschland mitfahren, oder?
Moment, da sind ja gar keine Instrumente drin.
Seht ihr das?
Da ist ein Display, aber da unten, da fehlt doch alles Mögliche.
Also wenn das nicht Scam ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Okay, also zu geben scheinst das WTF, Alter.
Die sind hart drauf, die Chinesen, ne.
Ultraschall mit...
Die haben aber auch alles, oder?
Die haben aber auch alles.
Die haben Schiffe, Gaming-PCs, Elektroauto, Drohnen, Transporter, LED-Bildschirme.
So, haben die irgendeine Bewertung?
Feedback?
Die haben null Bewertung.
Ja, das wirkt schon sehr vertrauenswürdig alles.
Super weiß, Leute.
Die ist nicht einfach nur weiß, die Grafikkarte, die ist super weiß.
Dabei ist die gar nicht weiß, sondern eher grau.
36k Grafikkarte
Dafür könnte ich mir auch schon die Yacht kaufen
26k, ja
Siehste, dafür könnten wir uns auch schon die Luxusjacht
Bei dem anderen kaufen
Die Luxusjacht
Oh man
AliExpress ist immer wild, ey, ich sag's euch
Aber ich hab da öfter schon bestellt
Und bis auf einmal
lief auch alles gut.
Ich hab da aber jetzt nie
ultra teure Sachen bestellt.
Ich hab da jetzt nie für tausende Euro bestellt.
Ja.
Wir haben doch letztens ein Video vom Bauer
geguckt, der bei Alibaba
glaube ich bestellt hat
Kupferplatten
und äh
quasi beschissen wurde.
Achso, ich dachte, die verkaufen hier neuerdings auch Gewehre
Wie gesagt, also bei AliExpress wundert mich nix
Oh man
Ein iPhone Pro Max
Für 58 Euro, auch nicht schlecht, oder?
Moment
Ach ne, Moment, das ist jetzt gar kein iPhone
Das ist ein i17 Pro.
Cheapated.
Android Smartphone.
Die China-Kinesen, Alter.
Das ist so geil.
i17 Pro Max.
Nein, soll überhaupt nicht irgendwie Leute verwirren,
dass die denken, das wäre ein iPhone oder so.
Überhaupt nicht.
Null.
Es sieht auch nicht absichtlich so aus oder so.
Das AliExpress ist echt immer richtig wild.
So, aber zurück.
Zurück zu GitHub-Trends.
Wir sind ein bisschen lahm.
Edgar at Home-Trend.
Open Tofu-Trend auch.
Temporal Service.
Was soll denn das sein?
Haben wir das schon mal aufgemacht?
Temporal Service.
Okay.
Was?
Das ist so eine Art Cloud Functions oder sowas.
Okay.
Ok.
So, was trendet denn...
Moment, Language Go?
Ohne Language hatten wir schon, ne?
Ne, hatten wir auch nicht.
Achso.
Headroom.
Das hatten wir schon mal.
AI.
Microsoft Web-Coded Tool.
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, kein AI, kennen wir aber schon, AI, hatten wir gerade, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, okay, top.
Also ganz ehrlich, die nicht language-spezifischen Sachen kann man eigentlich mittlerweile fast schon skippen.
Was trennt ihr denn so im C-Sharpland?
Rust gucken wir auch gleich.
Open-Claw-Windows-Node.
Oh je, AI.
Optimizer-Duck.
Irgendein Windows-Optimierungsding.
Wisst ihr, ich bin ja echt immer begeistert,
wie lange sich so Sachen hält.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
zu Zeiten, wo ich noch so...
Computerzeitschriften gelesen habe, ja,
dann gab es dort immer
so Artikel, so 95
Tipps, die nicht mal Microsoft kennt.
Hier, Gratisversion,
TuneUp 95 und sowas.
Witzig, dass es den Kram
heute immer noch gibt. Also anscheinend ist das heute
relevanter sogar noch
als früher, dass
Windows optimist werden muss und
deploted werden muss.
Mein Vater hatte damals immer
TuneUp 98 oder irgendwie so ein
Kack installiert.
Falls das so hieß.
AVG Tune-Up.
Ja, diesen Schrott hat er immer installiert gehabt früher.
Das war halt komplett...
Wie nennt man das denn?
Was, was kein Virus ist, aber ist quasi so...
So Fake...
Scareware.
Scareware heißt das, glaube ich, gell?
Ja.
aber es ist anscheinend immer noch so
wobei ich mir hier vorstellen könnte
dass das
wahrscheinlich, ich meine es ist immerhin
Open Source und hat ordentlich viele Sterne
wipecoded
dass sogar noch irgendeinen
Anwendungszweck hat, ja
weil bei Windows musst du halt viel rumfrickeln
oder
musst nicht zwar, kannst viel rumfrickeln
Das ist quasi ein Frontend für YouTube-DLP?
Fluent Layout.
Flyout. Fluent Flyout.
Ja, wer...
Also, da bist du echt
angeschissen, wenn du
Native Windows Apps im Jahr
2026 entwickeln sollst.
Was nimmst du?
Nimmst du WinUI und wirst abgefuckt?
nimmste Maui, wirst abgefuckt
nimmst WPF, wirst abgefuckt
nimmst Windows Forms, bist abgefuckt
kannst Avalonia nehmen
da bist du zwar auch wegen XAML abgefuckt
aber wenigstens kannst du deine Anwendung gleich cross-platform machen
aber Windows Desktop Anwendung ist abfuckt
kannst du einfach Elektron nehmen, wie das alle anderen machen
und 800 MB RAM für deine Mini-Anwendung verbraten
Ich bin auch Windows Forms Enjoyer
Allerdings, muss ich sagen
halt nur für so Sachen wie
man malt da selbst was rein
zum Beispiel
Windows Forms ist immer noch am besten, meiner Meinung nach
wenn man so Sachen machen will
wie, ich will ein Video
also wir haben mal beispielsweise im Stream
haben wir mal ein
Videoplayer
mithilfe von FFmpeg gebaut,
der über DirectX
über DirectX
die Sachen gemalt hat ins Fenster.
Dafür ist Windows Forms gut,
weil es kommt ja halt nicht in die Quere.
Und es war sauschnell.
Das war ein Ersatz.
Das war als Ersatz hierfür geplant.
Weil das ist eine WPF Anwendung aktuell
Ihr seht es vielleicht unten links
Seht ihr das unten links blinken
Wenn ich hier drauf klicke
Wenn ich schnell drauf klicke
Ja sieht man
Das liegt daran, dass das Fenster
Nicht schnell genug geheidet wird
Bevor es minimiert wird
Das ist ein Bug in WPF
Und wir hatten mal eine Anwendung programmiert
Die ich als Ersatz benutzen wollte
Für dieses WPF Overlay was ich hier habe
Habe ich aber nie verwendet
Aber es war schnell
IL-Spy.
Das ist für .NET.
Decompilation, genau.
Bulk Crap Uninstaller.
Ja, das braucht man halt leider unter Windows.
China-Chinesen.
China-Chinesen-Kram.
KI, Aspire, wo ich bis heute nicht gecheckt habe und es mir auch keiner wirklich erklären konnte, warum ich Aspire verwenden sollte.
Ich checke es einfach nicht. Ich bin da zu dumm für.
Chat, wenn ihr das lest, versteht ihr dann, um was es geht?
Aspire is a multi-language, code-first toolchain for building, running and deploying distributed applications.
Ich verstehe nicht, wofür das da ist.
Ich habe da sogar schon Web...
So Web... Wie nennt man das?
Konferenztalks zugesehen.
Ich habe den Sinn davon immer noch nicht verstanden, wofür Aspire da ist.
Microsoft hat es vor ein, zwei Jahren ja richtig krass gepusht.
Aber ich checke es immer noch nicht.
Ich weiß einfach nicht, wofür das da ist.
Ethereum.
Oh, wir haben jetzt auf der Arbeit auch selbst
Ethereum-Nodes laufen.
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin
bei unserer
Blockchain-Initiative,
Offensive, wie auch immer
man es nennen mag, dabei.
Schon seit 3 Jahren quasi,
seit ich da bin. Und wir haben jetzt
selbst Ethereum-Nodes laufen.
Allerdings unter Linux,
nicht unter Windows.
Achso, das ist ein Execution Client.
Bin ich mal gespannt,
wie gut das läuft.
Weil unsere Polygon Nodes
machen immer Probleme.
Terraria Mods.
Powertoys.
Okay, das ist mal was Sinnvolles.
Im...
Converter. Was?
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Was, was, was, was, was?
Äh.
Was?
Chat.
Ist das irgendein...
Ein File-Converter oder was?
Ich hab keinen blassen Schimmer,
weil ich überhaupt sehend bin.
Aber ist anscheinend saubeliebt.
der im converter alles klar intro skipper automatisch die detect and skip
intro credit sequence in jellyfin okay das klingt tatsächlich ganz nice für die
ganzen leute die sich linux distribution stream per jellyfin die können dann das
intro skippen
Unity MCP.
So, gucken wir mal.
Was trendet denn bei Rust?
Blazingly fast, Leute.
Hatten wir schon.
AI.
FFF.
Ripcrap.
Hier habe ich gelesen,
der,
ich glaube, der war das,
Der Burns Sushi, da habe ich letztens einen Blogpost von dem gelesen, der hat richtig die Arschkarte gezogen, der hatte eine Entzündung am Gehirn, hat in seinem Blog gestanden und dadurch hat er Halluzinationen bekommen.
und der ist dann ins Krankenhaus, in die Notaufnahme
und die haben ihn untersucht und haben gesagt, du hast nichts
und haben ihn in die Psychiatrie gesteckt.
Und das hat dann erst ein paar Wochen gedauert oder Tage, ich weiß nicht genau, gedauert,
bis die erkannt haben, der gehört nicht in die Psychiatrie,
der braucht Medikamente gegen die Entzündung am Gehirn.
Das hat er auf seinem Blog geschrieben.
Richtig abgedrehter Scheiß, Alter.
Aber es geht ihm glücklicherweise wieder besser.
Anscheinend ist er auch wieder hier am entwickeln
Committed two days ago
Der ist krass drauf, oder?
Er ist doch im Krankenhaus mit Entzündung am Gehirn
Und vor zwei Tagen
Kommit
Also ich glaube, ich glaube, der war das.
Ich glaube, von dem habe ich das Blog gelesen.
I, I, I.
Ach, das hatten wir schon mal und ich habe nicht gecheckt, was es ist.
Open Shell AI.
Litter.
Ich glaube, das klingt wie was mit Katzen, aber das war auch AI.
Ja, AI.
Android Client for Codex.
Codex.
Modern Editor.
Okay, AI.
Talk Music, AI.
Mystical AS, AI.
AI.
CSS Engine.
Server ist doch eine CSS Engine in Rust, oder?
Was so ein Besuch so macht, die liegt draußen auf der Liege gerade.
Übrigens, ich habe erkannt, es ist gar keine die, es ist ein der.
Gibt es neue Bilder? Ja, ich habe ein paar Bilder gemacht, aber nicht gepostet.
Web Browser and written in Rust, so war das.
Full Stack App Framework
for Web, Desktop und Mobile
Dioxus
Ein App Framework
für Desktop und Mobile?
Taugt das was?
Sowas ist ja prinzipiell
nicht schlecht, wenn es mehr Alternativen gibt
und man nicht zwangsläufig alles in Elektronen
bauen muss
Es ist halt Rust
Das ist also quasi dementsprechend
Default ein bisschen eklig.
Aber immerhin durchdacht eklig.
Nicht so wie C++.
Das ist eklig und undurchdacht
eklig.
Hat ein bisschen was von Svelte, oder?
Oder von React.
Use Signal Count.
Wisst ihr, was richtig gut wäre?
Wenn die jetzt anstatt dem
Screenshot von dem Code noch daneben
eingeblendet hätten, wie die Anwendung dann aussieht.
Ah, hier.
Oh, guck mal, es gibt
Hot Reloading.
Wie hat er denn das gemacht? Das ist ja cool.
Hot Reloading
für Mobile Apps.
Also, nicht Mobile, für Web Apps.
Ja, das sind PWA's dann im Endeffekt.
Höchstwahrscheinlich.
Cool.
Coole Sache.
Aber unter der Haube.
Unter der Haube
verwendet das doch auch einen Browser, oder?
Weil wenn ich hier schon sehe,
Websockets und sonst was.
Experimental Native Render.
Render using WebSys, WebView,
ServerSideRendering.
Okay, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist quasi so eine Art Elektron, oder?
Nur irgendein Rust-Wrapper drumherum.
Weil das ist ja offensichtlich ein Browser.
Hier.
Bundle for Web Desktop.
Okay.
Was für eine Browser-Engine verwendet der denn?
Oder verwendet er jeweils die Native Components, falls sie da sind.
Also quasi WebView 2 unter Windows, LibGTK, LibWebKit unter Linux.
Das würde mich jetzt tatsächlich mal interessieren, was die da verwenden.
Keine Ahnung.
Das wäre doch echt mal ganz interessant, oder?
Oh.
Gut, aber mit Rust
eine GUI-Anwendung machen, das würde ich mir
wahrscheinlich eh nicht geben.
Chat in was? Mal angenommen.
Mal angenommen, ihr wollt
eine App bauen
und
was könnten wir da mal
als Beispiel nehmen für eine App? Irgendwas
Simples, ja? Also was nix, was
jetzt irgendwie krasse Render-Performance
oder so braucht. Also mal angenommen,
ihr wollt eine App bauen für
euren...
Man kann bei euch Customized
USB-Sticks bestellen mit unterschiedlichen
Logos drauf.
Das ist ein bescheuertes Beispiel, ja?
Ihr habt einen Shop,
wo man Customized
USB-Sticks mit Customized
Cases bestellen kann.
Mit unterschiedlichen Logos und Dingern.
So, und jetzt wollt ihr eine App bauen,
eine Webseite bauen,
iOS, Mobile,
desktop ihr wollt alle plattformen abdecken dass die leute bei euch
customized usb sticks kaufen können und mit einem designer mit dem designer
drin für eure usb stick gehäuse okay so und wie in was würdet ihr das machen
gibt ja ein paar sachen zur auswahl ja ihr könnt das beispielsweise in elektron
machen ihr könnt das in avalon ja oder sowas
machen ihr könnt das in qt oder cute machen die haben ja anscheinend auch
Mobile Targets, glaube ich. Ihr könnt das in
Maui machen.
Ihr könntet das in Flutter machen.
In Go.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob es für Go ordentliche
Cross-Plattform-Frameworks gibt,
die das
alles könnten.
In was würdet ihr das machen?
Wales. Hab ich noch nie was von gehört.
Blazer.
Okay.
Aber wie verpackst du dann deine
Blazer-Anwendung
in eine Desktop-Anwendung?
Die auf Windows, Linux, Mac,
iOS und Android läuft.
PWA.
Na gut, aber wenn du über den Store distributen willst.
Chat, soll ich euch ehrlich sagen, ich glaube,
ich würde es mir
einfach machen.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich irgendwas JavaScript-basiertes
benutzen.
Also entweder tatsächlich Elektron oder
irgendwie Ionic oder
irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Irgendwas, wo es einfach ist,
Cross-Plattform-Plus-Sachen zu bauen.
Solange es eine simple Anwendung ist und man
nichts Spezielles da braucht.
Ich würde da
nix Experimentelles basteln.
Vielleicht würde ich Avalonia mal ausprobieren.
React Native, irgendwie sowas.
Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Ich würde es mir wahrscheinlich einfach machen.
Weil Cross-Plattform-Entwicklung
ist wahrscheinlich eh schon abfuck genug.
Also was ich
definitiv nicht verwenden würde, kann ich
jetzt schon sagen,
ist MAUI.
iOS Native entwickeln
und wie von Google angekündigt von der KI
in einer Android App.
Kann man auch machen.
Es gibt ja heute viele Möglichkeiten.
Das ist natürlich auch eine Idee.
Du brauchst einfach nur eine Webseite
mit JavaScript, HTML
und sagst dann, Cloud Code,
ich brauche das auch als
Windows, Mac, Linux, iOS,
Android Anwendung. Hier verbrat einfach
mal ein paar tausend Euro Tokens und lauf
eine Woche und mach. Und wenn du Glück
hast, kommt dann irgendwas raus, was halbwegs funktioniert.
Ja, das kannst du auch machen.
Das ist dann
Das ist ja dann nicht wirklich Vibe-Coding, weil du hast ja die ursprüngliche Anwendung selbst gebaut.
Das ist dann quasi Extended Vibe-Coding oder sowas.
Wie auch immer man es nennen soll.
Vibe-Coding-NG.
Rust-Destined und Miley-Search.
Miley-Search ist POG.
Ich habe nämlich gehört, das Wubblos-Archiv benutzt auch Miley-Search unter der Haube.
Max, ist das noch so?
Also wenn man hier was sucht, ja, wenn man hier zum Beispiel nach Streamtitel sucht und sucht nach KekW im Streamtitel, wo es enorm viele Streams gab, die...
Warum habe ich so viele Streams gehabt, die KekW heißen, Alter?
Äh, oder KekW.
Etu, Etu, ich kann das nicht nachmachen, den Typ.
Be true.
Ahi.
Ähm.
Das ist glaube ich powered by
Miley Search.
Das hier. Dass man hier
so schnell suchen kann im Archiv.
Boah.
das hat mittlerweile richtig viele Sterne.
Eins will ich jetzt noch mal kurz...
Wir sind jetzt durch mit Trends, aber...
Wie viele Sterne
hat OpenClaw eigentlich mittlerweile?
Ist das noch das größte GitHub-Projekt?
Ach, okay.
Es ist ein bisschen langsamer geworden.
Es ist ein bisschen langsamer geworden mit den Sternen.
Ich hab noch keine Anzeige verstanden.
Ah, hier. Guck, guck, guck. Hier, seht ihr?
Es ist ein bisschen...
Es ging ja hier ultra ab am Anfang.
Es ist ein bisschen langsamer geworden mit den Sternen.
Viel besser ist Hermes.
Okay.
Ja, das Buzzword schlechthin, was diese Sachen angeht, ist ja mittlerweile Harness, ne?
Harness nennen die das alles immer.
Also quasi so eine Anwendung, die die Agents dann managt drumherum.
Hermes ist jetzt der neue Scheiß, okay.
Der Star?
Ist das das Richtige, was ich hier aufmache?
185.000, okay.
Wir müssen mal bei Miley Search was testen.
Kann man bei Miley Search auch Wild Cards verwenden?
Ah ne, das macht es standardmäßig schon, ne?
Alles, was danach matcht.
Aber kann ich sowas sagen?
Das verwirrt es jetzt ein bisschen, wenn man
da ein Sternchen dazwischen macht.
Okay,
jetzt haben wir es ein bisschen kaputt gemacht.
Aber es ist
lustig.
Wo ist es ja auch nicht.
Ich meine, macht auch keinen Sinn.
So.
Chatkill.
Dann.
Gucken wir mal, ob es noch mal Updates gibt.
Wichtig.
Ich meine, wir haben schon seit einer Stunde keine Updates gemacht.
Da wird es aber Zeit.
Was?
Was ist das?
Keine neuen Updates.
Meine, Leute, meine, meine Packages sind schon eineinhalb Stunden alt.
Was mache ich denn jetzt?
Hast du eigentlich schon Omachi getestet?
Nee, mache ich auch nicht.
Ich habe eineinhalb Stunden alten Packages, Leute.
Ich fühle mich komplett outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Was mache ich jetzt?
Schrecklich.
Hast du deine Webseite eigentlich im Stream gebaut?
Ich habe die Webseite gar nicht gebaut.
Der Serious Max hat die Webseite gebaut.
Und die Webseite selbst ist auf GitHub, soweit ich weiß.
Oder?
Hier.
Guck mal.
Das Wubblos Archiv.
Go, Pocketbase, Swellkit, Tailwind, Wittstack und FFM Pack.
Richtig, das war das Ding.
Ja, also da hat er das richtig übertrieben hier.
Da hat er es richtig übertrieben.
In Go ist das programmiert, aha.
Du hast so mal ein Command-Line-Tool, WTF?
Alter.
Ich bin hin und weg.
Was für Five-Header-Leute wir hier haben.
Richtig PogChamp ist das
PogU ist das
Gut, dann würde ich sagen
Haben wir uns angeschaut, was auf GitHub so trendet
Wir gucken mal, was es auf YouTube zu gucken gibt
Und als erstes gucken wir uns das hier an
Jemand, der in Kobol
einen Shooter programmiert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Video was taugt.
Wir gucken aber, wir fangen zumindest mal an zu gucken.
Weil mich das echt interessiert.
Ich kann mir nämlich nicht vorstellen,
dass es irgendwelche Grafik-APIs
für GoBall gibt.
Max, hast du mitbekommen,
es gibt jetzt eine Frau, die sagt,
sie ist schwanger vom Wal.
Was, von Timmy?
Oder von welchem Wal?
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Ich dachte, Timmy ist tot.
Die Leute haben echt schon richtigen Schaden, ey.
Die haben richtigen Dachschaden, Alter.
Wobei, ich hab ja mittlerweile auch
Certified Dachschaden. Ich darf ja nichts sagen, ey.
Wobei, dann darf ich erst recht was sagen.
So.
Dann machen wir mal kurz hier die Musik aus.
Und schauen uns mal an, wie man einen FPS in COBOL programmiert.
Timmy hat auch einen KI-Song, ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Wir hatten, also auf der aktuellen Arbeit haben wir auch COBOL, aber wir hatten auf der alten Arbeit COBOL.
Das Problem war nur, also die hatten irgendein Problem mit der Kobol-Runtime, dass das nirgendwo mal drauf funktioniert.
Und wisst ihr, was die auf der alten Arbeit gemacht haben?
Die hatten einen Kobol-zu-Java-Transpiler.
Was es nicht alles gibt, oder?
Die haben quasi die alten Sachen in Kobol weiterprogrammiert und Transpiled zu Java und als Java-Programm laufen lassen.
Weil es sonst irgendwie nicht mehr funktioniert hat.
Aber die haben das nicht neu entwickelt, das war weiterhin der Kobold-Scheiß.
Jetzt auch so.
Und Cobol stand sofort vor. Es ist alt, verbose, verpasst die meisten Features, die sogar die schittigsten modernen Sprachen haben,
hat nicht mal einen Heap im echten Sinn der Welt und ist definitiv nicht für die Entwicklung von Spielen geschaffen.
Also was ist eine bessere Idee, als eine echte Zeit-Ratecast-Base zu machen?
Es hat keinen Heap, also man kann keine globalen Variablen in Cobol machen.
... mit all den Features, die man in einem Videobau erwarten würde.
Jetzt für einen kleinen Realitätscheck.
In einem modernen Engine kriegst du viele Dinge gratis.
Windows, Rendering APIs, Math Libraries, Asset Pipelines, Input Systems.
You generally don't even think about them.
Cobol gives you...
Ist das ein How-to-Basic-Video im Hintergrund, was ich da sehe?
Da habe ich schon ewig nicht mehr reingeguckt bei How-to-Basic.
...to basically none of that.
So instead of asking, how do I make a game, you end up with questions like,
how do I get pixels onto the screen?
How do I read binary files?
Wie mache ich ein Map Format? Wie mache ich sogar Vektormap, wenn ich halbe der Map Funktionen nicht erwarte?
Cobol hat offensichtlich keine Grafikbücherei. Also war meine erste Idee, nur ein Bildfile pro Frame zu veröffentlichen.
Das funktionierte, technisch gesagt, aber es war langsam und klang. Tausende File zu schreiben, um nur ein Screen zu simulieren.
Cobol hat nur global... Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Also ich hatte ja mal was in Cobol im Stream gebastelt, just for fun, aber das habe ich schon wieder alles verdrängt.
Ideal.
Und als das Programm die Frames zu FFPlay begann, hatte ich endlich eine bewegende Image.
Jetzt ist es gaming.
Ein kurzes Interjektion.
Wenn du dir das Video gefallen fandst, dann lass dir das Liken und Abonnieren an.
Als Pixels...
gekallt, so ein großer Unterschied wäre es jetzt auch nicht gewesen.
Der Spieler bewegt sich um diese Grieche, aber anstatt von oben nach unten zu schauen,
schreibt das Spiel eine Vor-Person-Aufgabe.
Da kommt das Ray-Casting rein.
Für jedes vertikale Kolumn von Pixeln auf der Bühne
schießt das Motor ein Ray nach vorne aus der Position des Spielers.
Das Ray reiht durch die Welt, bis es eine Wand-Tile trifft.
Wenn es das tut,
dann messen die Motor die Distanz zwischen dem Spieler und der Wand
und nutzen das, um zu entscheiden, wie groß die Wand-Schlange auf der Bühne sein sollten.
Ich meine, das ist ja in jeder Programmiersprache so.
Das Problem ist nur, dass Kobol eine abartig hässliche Programmiersprache und umständliche Programmiersprache ist.
Und jetzt повторierst du das für jede Kolumne von Pixeln und plötzlich hast du etwas, das wie ein 3D-Hall.
Das ist, was eine Basis-Implementation in Kobol aussehen würde.
Ah, yes.
Und wenn du die Kobol-Syntax ausfällig schiebst, ist die Logik, dass du zuerst die Richtung des Rheins komponierst,
Dann führst du ein wenig vorwärts, dann schaust du, ob du eine Wand erhielst.
Letztendlich tust du das, bis wir eine Wand erhielten.
Der Algorithmus selbst ist nicht die schwierige Sache hier.
Cobol kommt in den Klatsch, um dieses Kompetitiv zu machen, aber in den meisten modernen Sprachen
wäre der Array-Loop vielleicht 10 Läufe lang und du hättest wahrscheinlich einen Vektortyp oder eine kleine Math-Library benutzen.
In diesem Fall, aber, wärmst du deine Finger, weil du every little useful method you can possibly think of
und dann double that.
Man muss alle intermediate Werte manuell kompensieren, alles in genannten Variablen steuern und
Pattern benutzen, die eine moderne Sprache in eine einzelne Ausprägung kompensieren würde.
Das ist, was ein mehr zivilisierter Programmierer ein paar Anti-Pattern nennen würde.
Aber jetzt haben wir eine Welt, die korrekt rendert.
Also ist der nächste Schritt, den Spieler innerhalb davon zu verändern.
Du hältst die Position und den Angle fest.
Bewegung bedeutet nur, diese Werte zu reduzieren.
Wenn der Spieler vorwärts drückt, gehen wir in die Richtung, in die sie sich befinden.
editiert nur ein paar Zahlen, anstatt das neu zu entwickeln und nicht quasi 40 Jahre
testet Dinger zu haben.
Leute, ich schwul mal ein bisschen vor, ich brauche jetzt hier keinen Quickmuffs, ich
will einfach nur sehen, was rauskommt, ehrlich gesagt, am Ende.
Ich habe zuerst gespielt und was für eine Öffnung zwischen diesen beiden Sekten existiert,
alle stimmen der Welt zu.
Aber dieser Schritt ist immer noch einfacher als der volle klassische Doom-Renderer,
damit ich es in den aktuellen Renderer pluggen und spielen kann.
Aber du kannst die Unterschiede nicht wirklich visuell sagen.
Jetzt für die Feinde.
Hier musste ich ein bisschen pragmatisch sein.
AI, auch in den alten Tagen,
bis ich, der Spieler, in seinen eigenen Sektoren für das erste Mal rauskomme.
Boah, nett schlecht, oder? Nett schlecht.
Nett schlecht, sowas in Kobol zu basteln. Das ist schon krass.
Ich mein, der Lag muss ultra hoch sein mit dem FF Play Gerändere.
Aber das ist krasses ARR.
Es ist technisch ein 2.5D Doom-like Werk.
Das sollte man unbedingt per KI in Rust rewriten.
Ja, sehe ich genauso.
Aber es kann ja nichts passieren, weil wir sagen ja, make no mistakes.
Dann ist ja eigentlich ausgeschlossen, dass was nicht funktioniert.
Informatiker bei Lufthansa Systems.
Job zwischen Cyber Security und Software Entwicklung.
Dann schauen wir mal, was der so macht bei Lufthansa.
Ich habe in den News gelesen, dass irgendwelche Lufthansa-Flugzeuge wohl letztens irgendwas lahmgelegt haben am Frankfurter Flughafen.
Ich habe aber nicht weiter reingeguckt, was da los war. Aber da gab es wohl Probleme.
Das können wir uns angucken nachher.
Okay, auf geht's.
Die Luftfahrtbranche ist sehr abhängig von der IT.
Gerade bei größeren Sachen.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Was bin ich da sehend?
Die Luftfahrtbranche ist sehr abhängig von der IT.
Hier, was ist das?
I-Text-Area.
J-Button.
Create Password Panel.
Ist das Java?
Ja, ne?
Würde ich jetzt mal drauf tippen.
weil es, also gerade JButton
und so, und die Syntax
sieht auch Java-mäßig aus
New JLabel
ähm, was ist
denn, also JTextArea, JButton
und so, was ist das denn
für ein UI-Framework, ist das irgendwas
Java-Eingebautes?
Ist das sowas wie Swing, oder
ist das Swing, ja?
Sieht Swing nicht abgrundtief kacke
und hässlich aus?
Das ist doch das, was so grau-schwarz aussieht.
Ja, genau.
So.
Genau, so stelle ich mir Swing You Eyes vor.
Aber es gibt doch
Gibt es denn dafür wenigstens gescheite Skins
Dass das wenigstens so aussieht
Wie was modernes
Das sieht aus wie letztes Jahrtausend
Ja
Aber anscheinend ist das sowas, ja.
Jetbrains IDEs sind auch Swing, also geht...
Ach ja, wirklich, sind die das?
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, die rendern da irgendwie den Kram komplett selbst.
Okay, also anscheinend kann man das auch schön stylen.
Und was sagt ihr denn als diejenigen, die Swing schon mal...
also an diejenigen, die Swing schon mal verwendet haben,
ist das halbwegs angenehm zu verwenden,
weil so UI-Frameworks aus dem letzten Jahrtausend
sind meistens ziemlich altbacken vom Benutzen her.
Oder geht das? Geht das halbwegs klar?
Kann man sich das ein bisschen vorstellen,
wie das Windows Forms für Java,
wobei Windows Forms trifft es nicht so ganz,
Windows Forms läuft ja nur unter Windows.
Swing läuft ja unter jedem Betriebssystem.
Egal, guck mal weiter.
Gerade bei größeren Sachen,
das kann schon manchmal frustrierend sein,
wenn man irgendwie immer noch nicht die richtige Lösung gefunden hat.
Natürlich ist da auch ein großer Aspekt das Thema Sicherheit,
weil das natürlich ein sehr kritischer Betrieb auch ist.
Oh, da hätte ich jetzt auch nicht mit gerechnet.
Das wundert mich sehr.
Du warst zu langsam.
Er wundert sich, dass es funktioniert.
Moment.
Da gibt es doch dieses...
Ist das?
Nee.
Da gibt es doch diesen...
Den da meine ich.
It works. Why? It doesn't work. Why?
Manchmal fragst du dich auch, wenn es funktioniert,
worum es geht.
Ah, aber okay, jetzt kommt's.
Hi, mein Name ist Luca, ich bin Informatiker
bei Lufthansa Systems. Ein richtiger Informatik-Core.
Heute werde ich Features für den Check-In und Boarding-Prozess
implementieren und hoffentlich funktioniert alles.
Welche Browser-Extension nutzt du?
Hä?
Für was?
Was meinste?
Oder meinste allgemein?
Ich benutze
uBlog Origin
Volume Master für Streaming
Dark Reader
in manchen Browsern
und ansonsten
eigentlich nur noch für Twitch
dann FFZ. Das wars.
Mehr benutze ich nicht.
Ja, U-Block ist das Beste.
U-Block gibt es ja auch jetzt in der
Lite-Variante, glaube ich.
Ne, ich habe FFZ.
7TV benutze ich nur für Emotes
hinzuzufügen.
Browser-Extension benutze ich seit jeher FFZ.
U-Block gibt es ja auch wieder für Chrome.
Halt eine Lite-Variante, aber es ist immer noch
das Beste.
NoScript war früher richtig geil.
als man auch die ganzen einzelnen Sachen erlauben konnte und sowas.
Mittlerweile weiß ich gar nicht, ob es NoScript überhaupt noch gibt.
Und ob das noch entwickelt wird und ob das noch taucht, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Aber früher war NoScript pock.
Ich arbeite an Applikationen, die im Boarding-Prozess, Check-In-Prozess genutzt werden.
Hat er da eigentlich einen Applikationen?
Ist das ein Fahrradrucksack? Sieht ein bisschen... Ich hab's jetzt nicht erkannt.
... die im Boarding-Prozess, Check-In-Prozess genutzt werden weltweit an Flughäfen.
Natürlich ist da auch ein großer Aspekt das Thema Sicherheit.
Erstmal Tickets.
Worst Case wäre auf jeden Fall, wenn in Produktivsystemen Fehler auftreten.
Passiert eher selten, aber passiert auch ab und zu mal. Die Worst-Case-Fälle sind
halt oft auch die spannendsten. Macht natürlich dann schon auch Spaß daran zu
arbeiten. Genau, also ich sehe auf jeden Fall schon, dass über Nacht oder gestern
Abend nichts mehr super-Kritisches reingekommen ist. Ist schon mal gut.
Er hat jetzt eine halbe Stunde. Was ist, wenn er länger braucht?
Implodiert er an die Tastatur, oder?
Weil je nachdem, wie kompliziert die Bugs sind,
ist auch für eine halbe Stunde schon viel zu kurz.
Es macht ja auch Spaß, wenn man weiß,
okay, das kriege ich schnell durch und es wird auch direkt funktionieren.
Ah, guck mal, ein bisschen HTML-Stelz.
Gerade bei größeren Sachen, das kann schon manchmal frustrierend sein,
wenn man 6-7 Stunden wirklich nur durchprogrammiert
und irgendwie immer noch nicht die richtige Lösung gefunden hat.
Morgen.
Ah, eine Runde Daily.
Was macht er? Neue Features testen, Sicherheitslücken analysieren
und schließen Sicherheitsnormen für den Flugverkehr umsetzen, Arbeit dokumentieren.
Das macht er wahrscheinlich.
Ob er es wirklich macht, ist wieder die andere Frage.
Aber es ist doch ganz klar, guckt mal Leute, gerade im Flugverkehr müssen die Sachen doch fehlerfrei funktionieren.
Das heißt, man muss die gleich so bauen, dass sie keine Fehler haben.
Und wenn man eh schon sicher ist, dass die Software keine Fehler haben kann, dann muss man sie auch nicht dokumentieren.
Weil Dokumentation brauchst du ja nur, wenn was kaputt ist.
Und nachdem eh nichts kaputt geht, kannst du dir die Zeit sparen.
So eigentlich ganz logisch.
Kannst du noch einen vierten Bug fixen in einer halben Stunde.
Also die Routinearbeit für...
Ja, Tests und Kommentare brauchst du auch nicht.
Logisch.
Was ist das für Zeit spart?
Stell euch das mal vor.
Und die drei Bugs wette ich mit euch,
Ich wollte es gerade sagen, Potato Bob, die drei Bugs sind bestimmt auch alles Anwenderfehler gewesen.
Heute habe ich es jetzt erstmal hinter mir.
Was hat er gemacht? Daily Daily gemietet oder was?
Also die Routinearbeit für heute habe ich jetzt erstmal hinter mir.
Wir haben alles, was man so an IT-Infrastruktur wirklich auch am Flughafen findet.
Also hier haben wir zum Beispiel Quickboarding-Gates.
Eine Funktionalität der Applikation ist auch, dass man eine Emergency-Notfall-Message an den Werkschutz verschicken kann.
Das kann zum Beispiel ein medizinischer Notfall sein.
Jetzt hat das Kamerateam gesagt, guckt beide mal besonders fokussiert.
Was ich mir hier vorstelle, ist, wenn wir hier unten drunter noch ein Eingabefeld haben, wo der Werkschutz eintippen kann.
Der Krankenwagen ist informiert.
Es ist eindeutig, hier Java sieht wirklich sehr nach Swing aus, oder?
Auch hier dieses schattierte Häkchen-Ding und so.
Oder der Fraport-Sicherheitsdienst wurde informiert.
Soll es dann aber auch möglich sein, dass man keine Antwort eintippt?
Ich würde es tatsächlich so machen, wenn wir keine Antwort eingeben, dass dann trotzdem der Knopf sichtbar ist.
Und wenn er gedrückt wird, dann wird nochmal eine Meldung zurückgeschickt an denjenigen, der ihn ausgelöst hat mit der Information.
Der Notruf, der wurde empfangen.
Das ist schon eher eine komplexere Sache.
weil das...
Boah, ey, da könnte ich mich nicht konzentrieren,
wenn die ganze Zeit mein Chef neben mir hockt
und bei mir auf den Monitor guckt.
Einerseits die Oberfläche betrifft,
das heißt, es muss ja irgendwie in der Oberfläche eine Möglichkeit geben,
wirklich eine Antwort einzutippen,
aber auch den Logikteil im Hintergrund.
Gerade wenn man dann doch irgendwie ein bisschen logischere,
anspruchsvollere Aufgaben hat,
ergibt das schon Sinn,
sich das vorher noch mal auch bildlich vor Auge zu führen, damit man das auch durchplanen kann.
Das ist auch Inhalt des Studiums, da lernt man das auch schon.
Ich glaube, das reicht mir erstmal.
Dann kann ich jetzt mit dem Stand zurück an meinem Arbeitsplatz, kann versuchen...
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass er normalerweise ein Diagramm dafür malt.
...das zu entwickeln.
Das Feature muss heute fertig werden.
Moment, wer plant denn diese Dinger?
So, by the way, ich hab mir überlegt
Wir könnten da noch ein
Rückmeldung einbauen
Für Notruf, aber
Das muss heute fertig werden
Was ist das denn für eine Planung, Alter?
Die müssen mal ordentliche Sprints machen
Die sind nicht agile genug, Leute
Da muss erstmal
Gesprint plant werden, gesprintet
Reviewen werden, Sprint refined werden
Sprint retrospektiert werden
die sind überhaupt nicht agile genug.
Die machen viel zu wenig
Verwaltungskram drumherum.
Da war ich in der Schule sogar.
Dann kam mittendrin der Anruf.
Dann durfte ich kurz rausgehen
und das Gespräch annehmen.
Und dann habe ich mündlich da die Zusage gekriegt
für das To-Alles-Stück.
Habe ich mich sehr gefreut.
Also ich wurde angerufen und eingeladen
zum Vorstellungsgespräch.
Da war ich gerade im Bauhaus Weihnachtsbaum kaufen.
Vor drei Jahren.
Da kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern.
das geht doch durchaus klar oder
also für einen stieg
und einstieg geht das klar
Also bei mir ist das so, dass vor allem die
Praxisnahen Vorlesungen
Für mich einen großen Vorteil hatten
Ist nicht sein Gehalt?
Wie?
Ist nicht?
Was ist das sonst?
Also klar, der muss auch Steuern drauf bezahlen
Heißt im Endeffekt
ihm bleiben hiervon halt noch
3500 Euro übrig
oder sowas.
Dann später.
Und jetzt irgendwie 2500
oder so.
Achso, achso, achso,
achso, okay.
Also bei mir ist das so, dass vor allem die praxisnahen Vorlesungen für mich einen großen Vorteil hatten für auch das Berufsleben.
Tendenziell sind aber auch die theoretischen Vorlesungen, wie zum Beispiel Grundlagen der Logik,
Vorlesungen, die im Berufsalltag sehr wichtig sind, weil man dann ja doch häufig vor komplexen Problemen steht.
Da ich an dieser Stelle schon mal vor einiger Zeit gearbeitet habe.
Okay, Chat, wir machen jetzt den Test mit euch.
So.
Also, Chat.
Exklusiv oder.
Was kommt raus?
0x0.
0.
Okay. 0x01. 1. 1x0. 1. 1x01. 0. Okay, ich sehe schon, der Chat kennt sich aus.
Excellent
Ich glaube aber, dass sie ein bisschen was
Komplexeres machen
Als das im Studium
Ich habe extra ein bisschen
Was komplizierteres genommen
Wie viel IQ war das?
Ja, nicht so hoch
Es gab glaube ich erst eine Subscription heute
Oder ich habe es übersehen
Der IQ, da geht noch deutlich was
Ich würde sagen, wir sind jetzt so bei 105 gerade vielleicht.
Ähm, habe ich mir den groben Ablauf schon mal dokumentiert gehabt.
Also das spart mir bestimmt jetzt eine halbe Stunde einfach,
die ich sonst erst mal mit Suchen beschäftigt wäre.
Jetzt kann er loslegen mit Programmieren und starten mit dem Design.
Okay.
Ich habe es selber noch gar nicht getestet.
Ich kann es auch beim Entwickeln gar nicht live sehen.
Deswegen schauen wir uns jetzt erst mal gemeinsam an, ob das schon mal funktioniert hat.
Ja.
Ein Textinput.
Hier ist jetzt schon mal eine Möglichkeit,
was einzutippen.
Aha, das Callbalken
gefällt ihm nicht.
Das kann ich verstehen.
Weil, wenn man nicht mehr als so eingeben darf,
von der Menge her, dann kann man das auch wegmachen.
Da weiß ich auf den ersten Blick
gar nicht genau, wie man die jetzt
sofort entfernt, aber das ist dann auch ein guter Anwendungsfall für die KI.
Dafür haben wir direkt in unseren Entwicklungsumgebungen
integriert. Okay, Chad, lass mal kurz gucken.
Swing, Remove, Text Area,
Scrollbar.
Okay, so.
Also das ist glaube ich nicht sonderlich kompliziert.
Guck mal hier.
Hier. Da.
Scroll Plane Never
kann man angeben. Hier so findest du es.
Also das kriegt man auch ohne KI raus.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
ich hätte es wahrscheinlich auch einfach
irgendwo bei
ChatGPT oder irgendwo bei
Oh, guck mal da.
Die haben Cloud Code am Start reingepastet.
Also ich kann die KI jetzt befragen, wie ich die Scrollbar entfernen kann.
Die Lufthansa haut Tokens raus.
JetGPT hat erstmal gesagt, das ist eine sehr gute Idee, die Scrollbar zu entfernen.
Das macht die ganze Anwendung gleich viel angenehmer nutzbar.
Oder sowas.
Der hätte, der hätte, ChatGP hätte erstmal geschwätzt.
Um die Scrollbar anzupassen, hast du drei verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Bla bla bla bla bla bla.
wenn es letztlich klärt sich swing gotcha wäre das ein typischer anwendungsfall wo man ganz
gut auf k.a. das ist genau das was wir es der grau verflogen sind das genau das macht es
nicht rausgefunden haben vertical scrollbar never also das geht auch ohne ki
Wenn es funktioniert, wäre das ein typischer Anwendungsfall, wo man ganz gut auf KI zurückgreifen
kann.
Genau, dann testen wir jetzt nochmal nach, ob die KI uns gut unterstützt hat.
Das ist ein Touchscreen, oder?
Die touchen da normalerweise drauf.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Die KI hat seine ganze Arbeit gemacht.
Warum braucht es dich denn einfach?
Also das war ja jetzt wirklich nur ein kleiner Schönheits...
Naja, ich behaupte mal, den Textinput hätte die KI auch hier gekriegt.
Das ist ein Fehler, den wir da behoben haben.
Wenn es dann wirklich um große, logische, komplexe Probleme geht,
da kommt die KI dann doch irgendwann auch an ihre Grenzen.
Man muss natürlich schon auch sagen, dass da wichtig ist,
dass man selber noch die notwendigen Fachkenntnisse hat,
einfach um der KI die richtigen Anweisungen zu geben.
Aber man muss es vor allem checken.
was da passiert ist.
... aber vor allem auch um die Ergebnisse, die die KI dann liefert,
überhaupt bewerten zu können.
Und um offensichtlichen Bullshit, den die KI verzapft, auch direkt sehen zu können.
Ich sag nur, diese komische Funktion, die dein Heimatverzeichnis gelöscht hätte,
ist auch aus Versehen, wenn du es ohne Parameter aufrufst.
Alleine erstmal, dass man dieses ganze Konstrukt versteht, das ist schon, glaube ich, eine Herausforderung.
Ich habe auch schon eigentlich eine Idee, wie ich das umsetzen werde, die Logik dahinter.
Also eigentlich müssen wir jetzt nur eine SOS-Nachricht verschicken und dann können wir direkt testen,
ob auch das Antwortfeld angezeigt wird oder nicht.
Und dann kann Stefan direkt bewerten, ob es ihm gefällt oder nicht.
Ja, das sieht doch schon besser aus.
Hier ist jetzt noch ein Freitextfeld.
Wir können hier irgendeinen Text reinschreiben.
Komme sofort.
Und wenn wir jetzt hier auf Acknowledge drücken,
müsste quasi diese Nachricht zurückgeschickt werden
an den ursprünglichen Sender.
Und perfekt.
Bist du zufrieden, Stefan?
Ja, also ich finde, du hast das Popup ein kleines bisschen anders implementiert,
als wir es eigentlich aufgemalt haben.
Mir gefällt das so tatsächlich noch ein bisschen besser, wie du es gemacht hast.
Da war einfach so mehr Platz haben, um die Schaltflächen auch richtig zu beschriften.
Ich finde, das wirkt auf jeden Fall sehr intuitiv.
Also finde ich super gelöst, die ganze Implementierung.
Aber das ist schon ein Touchscreen normalerweise, oder?
Damit ist das nächste To-Do erstmal abgearbeitet.
Aber zumindest scheint er eine halbwegs gescheite Tastatur zu haben, soweit man es erkennen kann.
Das muss natürlich jetzt noch genauer nachgetestet werden, das darf der Stefan dann übernehmen.
Gerade wenn man jetzt einen Tag lang nur programmiert oder sich die ganze Zeit nur konzentrieren muss.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, es gibt ja ganz viele so Technikläden, wo so Tischkicker rumstehen.
Ich hasse Tischkicker-Kram.
Ich mache das überhaupt nicht gerne.
Und wenn, muss ich richtig dazu überredet werden
und habe dann beim Spielen überhaupt keinen Spaß.
Ich hasse das.
Ich kann das überhaupt nicht ab.
Und es ist auch übelst langweilig.
Das kommt auch noch dabei.
Bietet sich das schon an, auch irgendwie mal den Kopf freizukriegen?
Ich würde dann lieber, also ganz ehrlich,
wenn es darum geht, würde ich lieber eine Runde spazieren gehen.
Irgendwie zum Bäcker ein paar Brötchen holen, fressen, bisschen frische Luft, dann kann man weiter Progaststelz machen.
... damit man wirklich einen Ausgleich hat und danach sich auch wieder voll konzentrieren kann auf das Problem.
Ja! Sehr schön.
Ich habe gewonnen, aber ich musste natürlich heute auch performen.
Wenn es am Flughafen zu einem IT-Ausfall kommt, dann wäre das im Normalfall so, dass manuell
geboardet werden muss.
Das heißt, man muss eine Liste schreiben oder die Boardkarten einreißen.
Dafür haben wir Seaboarding entwickelt.
Damit kann man trotzdem noch offline die Geräte ansprechen, zum Beispiel auch die Gates öffnen,
Boardkartenleser ganz normal benutzen.
Wenn man dann so eine Teilkomponente aktualisiert,
muss man danach auch immer durchtesten,
ob wirklich jetzt noch die Gesamtfunktionalität gegeben ist.
Wir werden jetzt einfach wirklich mal versuchen, den Boarding-Prozess
durchzuspielen.
Kann auch sein, dass ich überhaupt gar nicht erst durch das Gate durchkomme.
Ich habe jetzt das hier, das linke Gate schon mal geöffnet.
Wenn ich jetzt die Bordkasse auflege, dann sehen wir, es funktioniert nicht.
Genau, dann sieht man auch...
Was war das jetzt?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Also erstmal muss ich jetzt hier durchgehen, sonst piept er gleich.
Es hat beim ersten Versuch nicht funktioniert, beim zweiten Versuch schon.
Also ich hätte jetzt damit gerechnet, dass es auch beim zweiten Mal nicht funktioniert.
In dem Fall hat es dann funktioniert, weil auch da wieder ein falsches Kommando verschickt wurde.
Da muss man dann aber immer auch nochmal reinschauen und es wirklich nochmal überprüfen.
Scheint ja super Top-Secret-Zeug zu sein, wenn es geblurrt werden muss.
Ich habe jetzt ja anhand von der Skizze, die ich mir gemacht habe, auch die Stelle im Code gefunden, wo das fehlerhafte Kommando geschickt wird.
das habe ich jetzt schnell angepasst und das können wir jetzt eigentlich direkt
wieder einmal kurz bauen und dann hinten im labor nach testen ganz ehrlich ich
finde das aber eigentlich ganz gut wie die das machen das gefällt ja ja wir
brauchen das und das und dann basteln keiner kein super krasses daily scrum
gemiete gemacht getrunken einfach noch das hat noch ein bisschen mehr
Bastelbuden-Charakter von früher, sag ich mal.
Ohne, dass ich jetzt mit meine, dass da Schrott rauskommt, ja.
Irgendwie gefällt mir das.
Ja.
Einer sagt, ey, da könnten wir doch noch das und das einbauen.
Glaubt, das ist ganz praktisch.
Fragt dann vielleicht mal nach.
Die Leute, die es benutzen, sagen auch, es ist ganz praktisch.
Und es setzt sich einer dran und baut das dann.
Drei Stunden Refinement, genau.
Nicht zu vergessen, erstmal Retrospektive machen, um zu gucken, ob es irgendwelche Blocker gab oder irgendwelche internen Ablaufprobleme und sonst was.
Und dann natürlich drei Stunden hintendran nochmal refinieren.
Das sieht schon mal gut aus.
Und unschur fixen, auch ganz wichtig.
Das ist genau das, was wir uns ja gewünscht haben.
Wenn ich den jetzt nochmal drüber halte, soll...
und planen für den nächsten Sprint dann gleich noch.
Ich abgewiesen werden. Genau. Da können wir dann auch nochmal schauen.
In der Passagierliste ist auch nicht jetzt nochmal die Person zweimal oder so vorhanden.
Das heißt, das ist schon richtig.
Bist du bereit?
Bin bereit.
Du warst zu langsam.
Aber okay, es kommt trotzdem.
Und ich sehe auch schon etwas
aufleuchten
auf unserem Bildschirm.
Alarm.
Hat alles gut geklappt.
Auch wenn ja dann doch ein paar Sachen
nicht so gekommen sind, wie erwartet.
Hat sich dann doch alles
noch irgendwie geklärt.
Was ich ja ganz cool finde,
Der macht ja auch tatsächlich was.
Also nicht wie manch andere
soll sich Jobs hoses zeigen,
sondern der hat ja tatsächlich jetzt
von Anfang
des Videos bis Ende des Videos
war der ja wirklich auch am was machen.
Was ist denn das?
Job Einstieg als Softwareentwickler
bei SAP. Oh Gott.
Ah, das haben wir schon gesehen.
Erstmal eine Runde ABAP, Leute.
Kontrolle bei Imbiss,
Buden und Lieferdienst, Gehalt und Job als Zollbeamter.
Oh ne, da habe ich jetzt keinen Lerf drauf.
Warum wir kein Glasfaser brauchen.
Naja, solange es was anderes schnelles gibt.
Eigentlich ist mir das Medium fast egal.
Solange der Rest passt.
Eigene Public IP.
mindestens 400 Mbit.
Ist mir das egal, ob das Glasfaser ist
oder was anderes.
Latency passt.
Routing passt dahinter.
Zu den wichtigsten Endpunkten.
Da habe ich keine Probleme.
Welches Medium ich dann letztendlich verwende,
ist mir eigentlich egal.
MonkaS.
RAM-Krise, was übrig bleibt.
Computex 2026.
Ach war das wieder, ist die nicht in Taiwan oder so? Wo ist die dieses Jahr? Also die ist ja immer gleich Taiwan oder? Taipei. Ist Taipei die Hauptstadt von Taiwan? Ja, gut.
einmal ganz davon abgesehen, ich würde mir auch
Instant Glasfaser ins Haus legen lassen, wenn die
bei uns mal endlich
was bauen würden
Hauptsache, dass es da ist
das heißt nicht, dass ich Instant
das jetzt vielleicht darauf umschreibe, aber ich würde
wahrscheinlich auch Instant darauf umsteigen, ganz ehrlich
Gigabit
versus 400 Mbit
und wir reden ja nicht nur von
400 MBit down,
sondern wir reden ja auch
nur von 40 MBit
ab. Ich meine, das reicht.
40 MBit ab ist auch genug
für das meiste, was man machen will. Aber wenn ich
die Möglichkeit habe, sagen wir 500 down,
500 ab oder irgendwas zu kriegen,
würde ich eher das nehmen oder
Gigabit up, down.
Wie ist das eigentlich bei Glasfasernanschlüssen?
Sind die jetzt mittlerweile synchron
oder nicht?
Also wenn ich
beispielsweise bei der Telekom
Glasfaserkram bestelle,
angenommen, das gäbe es hier, wäre es dann
synchron?
Die sind auch asynchron.
1000 zu 500,
ja gut, das ist aber auch
symmetrisch, meine ich. Ja, genau, nicht synchron,
hast recht, eher symmetrisch.
Aber 1000 down, 500 up,
ist auch in Ordnung, würde ich
sagen.
Ich glaube, damit
kommt man erstmal aus.
direkt 70 euro ist mir egal ich gebe so viel kram sinnlos geld aus da kann ich auch für
meinen internetanschluss noch mal ein bisschen mehr peter bernmann machen woher den da den da
mache ich dann okay guck mal ich bin hier auf der komputex in taiwan und
was ich überhaupt nicht verstehe, hier gibt es überhaupt nichts zum Thema KI.
Das ist für mich sogar jetzt ganz angenehm, weil ich keinen Bock habe auf noch mehr KI-Sachen.
Wir haben ja schon öfters KI-Kram und ich brauche ja nicht nur KI den ganzen Tag.
Ah doch, AI.
Er hat mich gebaited.
Ich habe gedacht, er meint es wirklich ernst.
Das hat mich schon gefreut.
Hätte mich zwar gewundert, dass das so ist
Hätte ich gedacht, kann doch eigentlich gar nicht sein
Aber ich hab's ihm wahrscheinlich
Wie sagt man, der Wunsch, das Gedanken
Oder irgendwie sowas, gibt's doch so einen Spruch dazu
Ja, ich hab mir gewünscht, dass es so ist
Aber es war nicht so
Scherz, es ist geradezu absurd
Wie viel KI-Zeug
Einem hier begegnet, das ist fast wie so eine Karikatur
Ich wär mir nicht mehr sicher, ob es überhaupt
Einen einzigen Stand gibt, wo nichts
Von AI irgendwo steht
Und wie das eben so ist mit solchen Über-Hypes, alle denken, sie müssten mitmachen.
Wie hier zum Beispiel der erste agentische Monitor.
Das hat die Welt gebraucht, Leute.
Unbedingt.
Und wisst ihr was?
Unter der Haube, witzig auch, dass es Lucky Claw heißt, unter der Haube sind es wahrscheinlich zwei Seiten langes If.
Und da ist nix agentic.
Ja, puh, ich habe zwischendurch wirklich laut lachen müssen, zeige ich euch gleich.
Tatsächlich hat man hier auch für Computex manchmal das Gefühl, als würde man direkt in so ein KI-Rechenzentrum reingehen.
Was ja auch Sinn ergibt, denn alle Firmen wollen da offenbar auch reingehen, also in das KI-Server-Business,
weil halt gerade absurd viel Geld in den Bau von KI-Rechenzentren fließt.
Und das Resultat ist dann, die PC-Komponenten für Nicht-Rechenzentrum-Produkte, die werden knapp und teuer, vor allem Speicher.
Weshalb immer weniger Privatleute PCs kaufen, ja halt Teufelskreis.
Und hier auf der Computex sieht man nun, wie alle versuchen, um KI, Ramageddon drumherum zu arbeiten.
Wie kreativ.
Ja, ich habe gelesen, AMD bringt jetzt wieder alte CPU-Sachen raus, die noch mit DDR4 funktionieren.
Das die Branche macht, das seht ihr in diesem Video.
Und außerdem auch noch ein paar andere sehr interessante Produkte hier auf der Computex.
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen.
Was ja eigentlich auch irgendwie witzig ist, ne?
Alle machen so KI und haben dann auf der anderen Seite Probleme, dass der RAM zu teuer ist.
Das ist ja so ein Teufelskreis irgendwie.
Hast du schon von VibeOS gehört, ja?
Da habe ich letztens bei Microsoft einen Vortrag zugesehen.
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Die sagen, oh ne, wir haben Probleme mit zu wenig RAM.
Aber lass mal ganz viel KI machen, was sehr viel RAM frisst.
wobei sich das mit der Zeit dann irgendwann abschwächt
irgendwann geht's ja nicht mehr
dann ist das Zeug so teuer
und an vielen Stellen so unsinnig
da jetzt noch irgendwas von
mit echter KI einzubauen
ja, weil ich brauche ich ein KI
ein KI-Fahnenkreuz oder so
auf dem Monitor, nee, das macht keinen Sinn
dann verlangsamt sich das wieder ein bisschen
aber
ich glaube, das wird noch ein bisschen dauern
Ich habe ja gerade von unnützen KI-Anwendungen gesprochen.
Ah, lass mich raten, die haben wieder Mammuts.
Ja, es gibt natürlich auch nützliche.
Mammut, Mammut, Mammut.
Da kommt unser Sponsor Mammut ins Spiel.
Mammut.
Für 11,90 Euro im Monat bekommt ihr hier Zugriff auf GPT, Cloud, Mistral, Gemini, DeepSeek, Perplexity,
sowie Flux und Nano-Banana für die Bildgenerierung.
Die neuesten Versionen werden direkt nach Veröffentlichung aktualisiert.
Ja, und der Preis ist echt ziemlich gut, wenn man bedenkt, dass alleine ChatGPT Plus über das doppelte im Monat kostet.
Mit Mammuth könnt ihr obendrein antworten, per Reprompting vergleichen, Dokumente und Bilder analysieren, personalisierte Projekte erstellen oder mit der Sprach-KI sprechen.
Mammuth ist ein europäisches Unternehmen mit strenger Datenschutzpolicy, alles im Starterpaket ab 11,90 Euro inklusive Mehrwertsteuer für Privatkunden.
Ja, wenn ihr das interessiert...
Wie kann das gehen?
Na wahrscheinlich, weil die das multiplexen können. Die können sich quasi große Kontingente kaufen und es verwenden dann halt einfach mehrere Nutzer und es kann besser ausgelastet werden. So stelle ich mir das vor.
Welt, ne, RIP Siebel,
aber wenn man heute auf die Website
geht, dann steht da gar nichts von Computern.
Also nur noch hinter AI steht
AI and Computing und sonst
steht da nur Computex ist die
führende globale
Messe, fokussiert auf AI
OT and Startups. AI
OT, hä? Artificial
Intelligence of Things. Ganz ehrlich,
das habe ich vorher noch nie gehört. Ich auch nicht.
Okay, liegt vielleicht an mir. Egal.
Ich auch nicht. Habt ihr das schon mal gehört?
Mit meinen ganzen heisen Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Wir sind hier nämlich dieses Jahr mit einem riesen Team aufgeschlagen.
Nice.
Für mich war auf jeden Fall die größte Überraschung, dass es hier große Notebook-Neuverstellungen gab,
die tatsächlich standardmäßig mit 8 GB RAM in den Handel kommen.
Noch vor einem Jahr, da gab es 8 GB nur in der absoluten Billigklasse für weniger 100 Euro.
Ab der Mittelklasse waren 16 GB Standard.
Und nun gibt es das Acer Swift Air 14.
Das kommt in Europa für 800 Euro und zwar ausschließlich mit 8 GB.
Weil, um die Preise niedrig zu halten, wird die Hauptplatine in hohen Stückzahlen nur in einer Konfiguration gefertigt, eben mit aufgelöteten 8GB.
Leute, ordentlich ist Linux drauf und das passt.
Guck mal, die Linux-Kiste von mir hier, der Mini-PC, ich habe aktuell auch noch 8GB drin.
Und das funzt wunderbar.
Gigabyte.
Ja, so ist halt die Realität.
Kann man Acer jetzt auch nicht vorwerfen.
Die Firmen müssen um das KI-Ramageddon halt rum improvisieren.
Halt auch Apple, die ja ihr offenbar ziemlich erfolgreiches MacBook Neo auch mit 8 GB für 700 Euro anbieten.
Ja und Acer will da ziemlich offensichtlich in dieser MacBook Neo Zielgruppe wildern.
Das sieht man auch an der Werbung, die ja schon ein bisschen an Apple herrscht.
Ein wenig.
Fühlt sich auf jeden Fall wertig an, also mit Alu-Gehäuse und so.
Aber das Acer Swift Air 14 kostet 100 Euro mehr als das Neo.
Dafür gibt es aber ein Inch mehr Display-Diagonale und es gibt bessere Anschlüsse, nämlich zweimal USB-C mit vollem Thunderbolt 4 und einer USB-A Buchse.
Beim MacBook Neo gibt es nur zweimal USB-C.
Es gab vor ein paar Jahren auch schon mal so einen Trend zu kleinen, nicht ganz so leistungsfähigen Notebooks.
Das nannte sich damals Netbook. Erinnert sich da noch irgendjemand dran? Das war auch mal so ein kleiner Trend für 1-2 Jahre.
Das waren dann so 10 Zoll Dinger, so ganz kleine Notebooks, recht stromsparend, nicht so leistungsfähig, aber günstig.
...PC mit jeweils USB 3 und USB 2, also sehr abgespeckt.
Und das Acer Display macht 120 Hertz, bei Apple gibt es nur 60.
Das Problem ist nur, 8 GB unter Windows 11 und unter macOS, die fühlen sich möglicherweise dann doch anders an.
Also wenn ihr viele Tabs im Browser offen habt, dann werden beide Betriebssysteme mit so wenig Speicher in die Knie gehen, auf jeden Fall.
Aber generell würde ich dann doch sagen, dass Windows 11 Stand heute mit 8 GB weniger gut zurechtkommt als macOS.
Auch Dell zeugt mit dem XPS-Streiten Macbook Neo Kontrahenten.
Hast du schon Camelot Unchained probiert?
Ne.
Das ist, die machen auf Ashes of Creation oder wie das hieß, sie releasen irgendwie einen kompletten...
Kackhaufen auf Steam,
um dann zu sagen, wir haben es doch probiert.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das ist tot, das Game, seit Jahren schon.
Ich meine, die entwickeln
das seit 13 Jahren und das Game
sieht aus wie nach einer Woche
übers Wochenende zusammengewurschtelt.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich spiel weiter Dark auf dem Freeshot.
Die können mich mal mit dem Scamscheiß.
Leider habe ich da 200 Euro
verloren, weil ich die damals gebackt habe,
als es neu war.
Das Lügehäuse kostet wohl auch 800 Euro in Europa mit 8 GB RAM, hat aber auch zumindest 120 Hz und sogar eine beleuchtete Tastatur.
Trotzdem kurze CT3003 Empfehlung, kauft euch keinen Computer mit 8 GB RAM.
Wenn ihr nicht so viel Geld ausgeben könnt oder wollt, dann nehmt lieber was Gebrauchtes.
Ja, und neue PC-Handhelds gab es auch, zum Beispiel das Asus ROG LIX20 mit fettem 7,4 Zoll OLED-Display und AMD Ryzen AI.
Sieht gut aus, ne, das Display. Sofern man das jetzt halt auf einem normalen Display vom Display erkennen kann.
Bei Xtreme oder das MSI Claw 8 EX AI Plus, kurzer Einschub, ohne AI geht es nicht.
Hauptsache AI.
Mit dem Intel-Konkurrenten Arc G3 und 9 Zoll LC-Display.
Das sind eigentlich interessante Geräte, finde ich, aber weil da eben so viel RAM drin ist, also 24 bzw. sogar 32 GB, werden die Teile voraussichtlich so teuer werden, dass ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass sich viele Menschen sowas zulegen werden.
Ja, ist leider so.
Das gleiche gilt auch für die auf jeden Fall meist diskutierten Computer auf der Computex, nämlich die ersten Notebooks mit Nvidia CPU und GPU, den RTX Spark Rechnern.
Also das mit den Preisen ist eine Prognose von uns, weil es gab so gut wie keine Infos zu den Teilen bislang, obwohl wirklich jeder relevante Notebook Hersteller so ein Teil angekündigt hat und die auch schon im Herbst kommen sollen.
Mein CT-Kollege Florian hat auf der Messe zumindest ein bisschen mehr herausgefunden, als die Hersteller sagen wollten.
Zum Beispiel, dass er davon ausgeht, dass der große Nvidia Notebook-Chip, Codename N1X, um die 45 bis 85 Watt verheizen darf.
Das Kühlsystem im Microsoft Surface Laptop Ultra mit dem N1X ist sogar auf 110 Watt ausgelegt.
Es wird aber auch eine abgespeckte Version des...
Wird aber ein warmes Notebook da.
ATX Spark Chips geben, der heißt dann N1, also ohne X, der wird sich so im Bereich 18 bis 45 Watt tummeln.
Ja und die große Frage ist jetzt natürlich, wie wird die Akkulaufzeit, weil die quasi Desktop-Version des ATX Spark, also der DJI X Spark, den haben wir schon getestet.
Und da haben wir damals im Leerlauf schon 20 Watt gemessen.
Das wird also auf jeden Fall interessant.
Apropos interessant fand ich die schönen OLED-Monitore, die man hier wirklich an jeder Ecke sehen kann.
Das Besondere, dass die nicht mehr wie noch in der Vergangenheit...
Die produzieren ja auch RAM. Es wird bloß eher für GPUs verwendet, die dann ins Rechenzentrum kommen.
... nur in recht dunkler Umgebung gut aussehen, sondern dass sie helligkeitsmäßig richtig
reinballern.
Tandem ist das Stichwort.
Das bedeutet, dass zwei oder sogar mehr organische Leuchtschichten übereinander liegen und so
mehr Helligkeit bringen.
Laut der Hersteller sinkt damit auch das Einbrennenrisiko, was ja bei OLED immer ein Thema ist.
hersteller bauen diese oled panels nämlich einmal samsung da heißen die qd
oled also quantum dots oled und einmal lg was auch noch mehr produzieren naja die
produzieren gerade das was für sie am besten ist von der menge zu dem was sie
verdienen können der markt regelt tatsächlich aber halt
gerade nicht so sehr für uns
Es gibt OLED-Monitore jetzt in sehr, sehr vielen Größenklassen.
Das war in der Vergangenheit ja noch ziemlich begrenzt.
Kurios fand ich zum Beispiel den ROG Strix OLED XG259QWPG, der als eSport...
Die haben natürlich tolle Bezeichnungen immer für ihre Displays, ne?
Das ist fast so geil wie Waschmaschinen.
Also ohne Scheiß, bei Waschmaschinen habe ich glaube ich mal die krasseste.
oder dümmste
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das überhaupt noch finde.
Warte.
Habe ich mal die dümmste Bezeichnung
aller Zeiten gesehen?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das noch
ob ich das hier noch finde.
Ich habe das doch
Ich hab das doch irgendwo mal gepostet.
Ah, oh, da hätte ich jetzt Bock drauf, Leute.
Wobei ich echt wenig Fleisch gefuttert hab die letzten Wochen.
Ich hab gestern sogar veganes Hackfleisch gefuttert.
Ich finde das Bild nicht mehr.
Ja.
Das war nämlich der schlimmste
Hier
Geile Produktbezeichnung, oder?
MC-32DG-7646CKTC
Ich glaube, das war für eine Mikrowelle, nicht für eine Waschmaschine
Für eine Mikrowelle
Hat da einfach einer einmal
Face-Rolled über die Tastatur, oder was?
Als sie sich diese Produktbezeichnung ausgedacht haben
Also das ist wirklich die beschissenste Produktbezeichnung, die ich je gesehen habe.
Na gut, für viel FPS ist das nicht verkehrt.
hat.
hatte jetzt aber auf der Computex so ein
Apple-Studio-Display-mäßiges Gerät
am Start mit OLED, 27
Zoll, 4K, 120 Hertz
und mattiert. Der Preisbereich
wird wohl so um die 650
Euro sein. Ja, und ich habe ja am Anfang
von unnützen KI-Funktionen
geredet. MSI hat tatsächlich
den ersten agentischen
KI-QD-OLED-Monitor
der Welt am Start.
Hä?
Also der Punkt ist, OLED-Monitor.
AI-Crosshair, Leute.
Was?
AI-Crosshair, was soll das sein?
Einen Punkt in die Mitte als Overlay
oder ein Kreuz in die Mitte als Overlay zu malen,
das ist nicht mehr.
Das muss per KI erledigt werden, oder was?
... der Welt am Start.
Also der Punkt ist, dass man da halt einen PC anschließen kann,
auf dem OpenClaw, beziehungsweise die von MSI angepasste Variante namens LuckyClaw läuft.
Und der kann dann Parameter des Monitors ändern.
Also statt den Knopf für die Helligkeit...
Ja geil, das hat die Welt gebraucht.
... kann ich meinem Claw-Assistenten texten,
Mach mal Helligkeit höher oder per Sprache halt.
Ich sag mal, das macht mein Leben jetzt nicht unbedingt besser.
MSI hatte mit dem MEG Vision X2 AI Plus auch direkt einen Komplett-PC am Start,
auf dem Lucky Claw nicht nur vorinstalliert ist, sondern wo auch im Gehäuse so ein Display eingebaut ist,
wo dann so ein animiertes Hologramm, also LC-Display, mit diesem MSI-Drachen.
Und mit dem kann man dann auch sprechen.
Konkret hatten die das auf der Computex so eingestellt, dass OpenClaw mit dem chinesischen Cloud-KI-Modell Minimax lief.
Die Sprachausgabe lief über Eleven Labs.
Und bei der Stimme, da hat MSI, also ich sag mal, nicht unbedingt die entspannteste Variante ausgesucht.
Warum sprichst du nicht immer so laut?
Hallo, alles klar bei mir?
Boah, ist das nervig.
Mit dem Ding würde ich nie reden.
Aber der Sinn davon ist, es ist komplett hängen geblieben.
Was, warum?
Warum?
Danke der Nachfrage, warum ich nicht laut spreche, das ist einfach mein Stil.
Freundlich und approachable.
Ich will dir helfen, nicht dich überfahren.
Klar und pragmatisch.
Ich bringe es auf den Punkt ohne drumherum.
Positiv und unterstützend.
Egal ob Gaming Laptop oder Business PC, ich bin auf deiner Seite.
Hauptsache KI, ja.
Professionell, ich bin zwar ein KI-Assistent, aber ich soll trotzdem menschlich rüberkommen.
Lautstärke ist nicht mein Ding.
Lieber bin ich der ruhige, verlässliche Typ, der dir bei MSI-Produkten ehrlich weiterhilft.
Gibt's was Bestimmtes, wobei ich dir helfen kann, ob Technikfrage, Produktempfehlung oder...
Das ist bestimmt auf Chat-GPT basierend.
Nee, oder hat er gesagt?
Auf was basiert das?
Weil der labert so viel.
Der labert so viel.
Das ist so ein typisches Chat-GPT-Gelabere.
Minimax.
Ah, okay.
Okay, das labert anscheinend auch gerne.
Ein bisschen Smalltalk.
Ich bin hier.
Und generell, man sollte eine sowieso potenziell gefährliche Software wie OpenClaw, die nahezu täglich Sicherheitsupdates bekommt, vielleicht nicht in einer Variante eines anderen Herstellers verwenden, bei der die Updates nicht zeitgleich durchgereicht werden. Wäre jetzt meine Einschätzung. Aber der Drache ist natürlich ganz niedlich. Was meint ihr? Gerne in die Kommentare schreiben.
Also dafür...
Da muss tatsächlich, ich sehe es so wie der Chat,
da muss der Chef gesagt haben,
ja, aber Moment, unsere Computer haben gar keine KI.
Oder haben ja gar nichts mit KI zu tun.
Baut mal KI ein. Da kam dann sowas raus.
Also dafür, ganz ehrlich, würde ich weder Geld ausgeben,
dafür würde ich eher Geld ausgeben,
damit das mein PC nicht hätte.
Das ist auch bei unserem 4004-Podcast,
auch hier auf dem Channel und überall, wo es Podcasts gibt.
Tschüss.
See you.
Ich hab wirklich die...
MonkaS.
Ich finde das immer kacke, wenn Videos direkt losgehen.
Was ist das?
Und das noch?
Microsoft's Bug Bounty
Betrays. Achso, ja, okay.
Das haben wir uns
ja sogar schon angeguckt.
Das ist dieser Typ hier, der irgendwas mit
Eclipse oder so hieß der doch
auf GitHub.
Hier
Nightmare Eclipse
Ach gibt's das nicht mehr?
Moment, haben die den gelöscht?
Die haben den gelöscht!
Die haben den Dude wirklich gelöscht!
Der wurde gebannt, weil er Microsoft ans Bein gepisst hat, oder?
Das habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt, dass der mittlerweile gelöscht war.
Ja, aber das Problem ist doch,
die Sicherheitslücken gibt es weiterhin.
Alter, Microsoft verkackt es mal wieder richtig, oder?
Auf GitLab wurde der auch ge...
Wie, der wurde auch auf GitLab...
Auf GitLab...
Hat Microsoft da bei GitLab angerufen?
Aha.
Na, kommen wir uns mal das Video zu an.
Also das habe ich mitbekommen.
Der hat es beim Bug-Bounty-Programm von Microsoft gemeldet.
Microsoft hat, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, wie das jetzt genau gewesen ist mehr,
Microsoft hat erstmal irgendwie nicht darauf reagiert, ne?
Und daraufhin wurden die Gerüchte laut, er hätte wohl einen offiziellen Backdoor gefunden.
War das nicht so?
Irgendwann hat dann Microsoft auch den Account gelöscht von ihm, wo er es reportet hat.
Und die wollten ihm keine Kohle ausbezahlen.
Wir gucken uns jetzt einfach mal das Video an.
die Bugs finden. Die Verbraucher bezahlen sie, um die Bugs zu finden. Sie geben ihnen auch den Kredit, um die Bugs zu finden.
Und dann gehen die Verbraucher weiter, um diese Sicherheitsprobleme zu lösen.
Die Benutzern der verletzten Programme werden vor den Kriminellen gesichert,
bekommen einen einfachen Copy-Paste-Exploit, der sie über vulnerable people's machines übernehmen würde.
Also die Bug-Bounty-Ökonomie ist geplant, um die Situation zu schaffen, wo jeder gewinnt.
Die Forscher, die Verbraucher und die Benutzern des Software.
Aber wenn diese Wirtschaft zerstört wird, wenn Forscher verabschiedet, unbezahlt, gebannt oder sogar mit legaler Aktion verletzt werden,
die Incentivestruktur zerstört und während all das passiert,
die Exploiten für diese Bugs nicht nur verschwinden, sondern sie gehen in der Tat in eine viel schlechte Richtung.
Sie sehen, Exploiten sind extrem wertvoll,
besonders wenn man eine findet, die dir ermöglicht, eine remote Maschine zu nehmen oder kriminelle Daten von einer Kooperation zu exfiltrieren.
Das sind die Arten von Exploiten, die Kriminalhackern den Top-Dollar bezahlen würden,
besonders die Ransomware-Gangs.
Hell, auch wenn man einen Exploit in etwas so Triviales wie einem Videogame findet,
das man in einem Spiel mit Items duplizieren lässt oder andere Unfähigkeiten bekommt,
würden die Leute immer noch bereit sein, Geld für diese Exploite zu bezahlen.
Das ist der Grund, warum man versucht, dass die Talent der Hacking für dich und nicht gegen dich benutzt wird.
So Microsofts preferred process for bug bounties is coordinated vulnerability disclosure or CVD.
In the clean version of that process, a researcher privately reports a vulnerability to Microsoft.
They investigate it, they build a fix, they ship an update, and then they pay out to the researcher.
And oftentimes they also credit them when appropriate so that the researcher gets a little bit more fame.
You know, maybe they get private contracts that they can work to make more money in the security industry.
Und nachdem die Patches geschickt wurden, posten die Forscher auch Informationen darüber auf ihren Blogs,
also machen sie den Exploit im Publikum, ohne nur den Attackern eine ungepatchte Waffe zu geben.
Das ist die Theorie, aber in Microsofts 27. Mai-Blog-Post sagte die Firma,
dass die Verletzungen von Nightmare Eclipses, die Blue Hammer, Red Sun, Undefend, Yellow Key, Green Plasma und Mini Plasma,
nicht verantwortlich ausgeschlossen waren.
Microsoft sagt, dass diese öffentlichen Beweise von Konzepten oder wirklich jeder POC für ungepatchte Verletzungen nie verantwortlich sind.
Und dass Microsofts Digital Crimes Unit weiterhin Fälle gegen Threataktoren und diejenigen, die kriminelle Aktivität ermöglichen, bringen würde.
Was sie also sagen, ohne es einfach auszulösen, ist, dass diese Verletzungen illegal sind,
Ja, aber Microsoft hat sich ja nicht gerührt.
Ja, aber erst nachdem das wieder eskaliert ist und das halbe Internet drüber geredet hat.
Das haben die doch garantiert mit Chat-GPT wieder erstellt, das Gelaber hier.
Anfang Anfang Anfang Anfang Anfang Anfang Anfang Anfang Anfang Anfang Anfang
Anfang Anfang Anfang Anfang Anfang
Anfang
Ja, auf Twitter wird bestimmt nichts gelöscht.
Außer er würde was gegen Tesla oder SpaceX machen.
Ansonsten wird es auf Twitter nicht gelöscht.
Genau.
die bugs to the company in der responsibel way that they asked for so
rather than the researcher just ignore the fact that das muss ich mal kurz
lesen chat sagt
jack mk ist auch eine katastrophe hatte den so mini sachen gemeldet cross side
request for three als glaube ich token leakage und einfach key lang nicht mehr
zeitgemäß erst kam nichts beziehungsweise eine info was die
nutzen das nicht der realität er schon dann haben wir es gefixt ohne mich zu
nennen überhaupt scheiße erspasten halten
ich sagte ich habe ja auch mal ein kamerahersteller gemeldet dass man das
gut passwort auslesen kann mit einem einfachen curl das die größte sorge die
er hatte war dass ich doch den anlistet link auf github wieder runter nehmen
soll das könnte ja jemand sehen
Ja gut, aber was soll er machen?
Ich war bei Microsoft und habe gesagt, nichts gibt es und er hat seinen Account gesperrt.
Was soll er denn machen?
were not posted to such a public forum,
then they would have probably been discovered
by someone else that may have more sinister...
Und deswegen, da kam ja dann das Gerücht auf,
oder die Verschwörungstheorie, könnte man fast schon sagen,
oder vielleicht ist es ja auch so, wir wissen es ja nicht,
dass das ein gewolltes Backdoor ist,
was quasi von der CIA oder sonst wem benutzt wird.
Ist ja immer so rumgeschmiert als Gerücht,
dass deswegen Microsoft das nicht fixen will.
Someone might have conducted a private sale of those exploits to a criminal organization on a dark web hacking forum,
where instead of this being something that's visible to practically everyone, it would have just had an exclusive black hat criminal audience.
At least on GitHub, there's a good chance for sysadmins and other people that are responsible to those potentially vulnerable systems
to test the exploits that were posted to GitHub in their own lab environments on their own devices,
which is completely legal by the way,
and then devise their own in-house mitigations to protect those systems
when Microsoft refuses to fix or even acknowledge that these problems exist.
But now that is no longer possible,
because Microsoft decided to ban Nightmare Eclipse's GitHub account,
thinking that it would prevent criminals from using the code against them.
Ganz ehrlich, ich weiß nicht, was mit Microsoft da los ist, weil sobald sowas mal im Internet war, kriegst du es nie wieder raus.
Und letztendlich sorgt es eher dafür, dass noch mehr Aufmerksamkeit darauf kommt.
Das ist schon merkwürdig, ne?
Fragt man sich, wie sie das hingekriegt haben.
Ich weiß nicht, gibt es von Microsoft größere Zahlungen regelmäßig an GitLab oder so,
wo sie gedroht haben, wir können es einstellen, weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, Google bezahlt ja auch zu einem großen Teil Firefox.
Wer weiß, was da im Hintergrund wieder läuft.
und sie den Forscher aus dem Versuch auslösen, um diese Bugs zu beurteilen,
dann stoppt die unverantwortliche öffentliche Ausgabe nur noch ein Ausgabendropfen.
Und es wird wirklich viel mehr so aussehen, als würde jemand versuchen,
die Alarm auf eine große Sicherheitspräzision zu kümmern, die bei Microsoft stattfindet.
Die Alarmsäule könnte chaotisch sein, aber wenn das Gebäude tatsächlich auf Feuer ist,
bliebe man nicht der Person, die die Feueralarm ausgelöst hat,
man bliebe den Leuten, die die Feuer tatsächlich erschaffen.
Ja.
Worum es geht, jemand, der bei Microsoft Sicherheitslücken reportet hat, wurde gebannt.
dann hat er die veröffentlicht dann wurde auf der plattform gebannt woran die veröffentlicht hat dann
ist auf eine andere plattform gegangen und irgendwie als microsoft geschafft dass dort
auch wieder gebannt wird und letztendlich wissen sie jetzt dadurch durch diese ganze sache mehr
leute als jemals zuvor so und die frage ist halt wird das microsoft patchen oder hat teilweise hat
das microsoft schon gepasht oder nicht weiß ich gar nicht ist der real legal action der
against nightmare eclipse because just posting a piece of code to github is not actually considered
hacking from a legal sense microsoft's own cvd page says that the vendor should coordinate with
the researcher throughout the investigation they should provide updates on case progress and when
attacks are underway they should work with the researcher on early public disclosure to protect
Das ist das, was Microsoft vergesst, wenn die Ausgaben sie schlecht sehen.
Vor allem mit der Yellow-Key-Vulnerabilität, die BitLocker verursacht hat.
Denn für viele Leute, mich selbst, sieht es wirklich aus, als hätte Nightmare Eclipse die Backdoor von BitLocker gefunden,
die Microsoft seit Jahren von der Gefängnisverwaltung gehalten hat, um in die Systeme der Menschen zu kommen.
Wenn Microsoft beginnt zu beweisen, dass ungeordnete Erklärungen einen Forscher in den Krosshäusern der Digitalen Krimi-Unit einstellen können,
ist alle Vertrauen aus dem Fenster.
Diese Forscher sind keine dummen Leute.
Sie können zwischen den Läufen lesen.
Wenn sie glauben, dass die Bewertung für die Beratung eines ernsthaften Verbrechens
von ihnen wird, dass sie geplattformiert werden oder mit der Gefahr, dass sie mit der Gefahr verbreitet werden,
dann werden viele von ihnen nicht die nächste große Verbrechung von Microsoft berichten.
Sie werden vielleicht selbst auf der Verbrechung sitzen.
Vielleicht können sie sich für die Menschen, die diese vulnerable Systeme nutzen, eine private Sicherheitskonferenz anbieten und ihnen ihre eigenen Mitgaben geben, die sie mitnehmen.
Oder sie könnten einfach auf der Dark Web gehen und den Exploiten den Hackermanns verkaufen, weil sie ja für Exploite bezahlen.
Oder sie könnten es anonym verleihen und es fällt ihnen in die Hände.
anyway. And out of all of these
outcomes, public disclosure
on GitHub might actually be one of
the least bad options for
the reasons I mentioned earlier.
The real danger here isn't a researcher
who went rogue and published exploits for the
world to see. The deeper issue
is Microsoft betraying the trust
of security researchers.
The Beef with Nightmare Eclipse might be the most
public one that Microsoft's had to date,
but there's hundreds of other
instances where security researchers'
time and resources had
been wasted by Microsoft refusing to pay out on bug bounties.
Wahrscheinlich hatten die bei Microsoft keinen mehr, der überhaupt gecheckt hat, was er ihnen
geschrieben hat, weil die alles nur noch vibecoden.
This erosion of trust is going to make fewer talented hackers bother spending their time
at all to find and report bugs, which is going to make the world's most widely used operating
system that much more vulnerable, especially with so much of it being vibecoded these days.
Ja.
Nice. GG, sellout.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das Ende von Gaming bei Nvidia.
Das können wir uns tatsächlich angucken.
Aber da gucken wir uns das CT3003 Video an.
Ich habe irgendwo schon mal was kurz, ich glaube auf Reddit gelesen,
dass Nvidia quasi die ganze Zeit nur erzählt hat, sie wollen irgendwie Talkings verkaufen oder so.
Ja, das kann ich mir... Ey, ohne Scheiß, Leute, ich kann mir das durchaus bei Microsoft vorstellen.
Ne, hab ich nicht, hab ich nicht. Soll aber ganz gut sein.
Das kann ich mir echt vorstellen, dass die sind ja mittlerweile so braindead am Vibe-Coden bei Microsoft,
dass die wahrscheinlich den report reingekriegt haben der hat es den
copilot reingeschmissen hat gefragt und von das wirklich copilot hat gesagt nee
nee gibt es keine probleme und dann hat das geschlossen so das kann ich mir
wirklich vorstellen dass das so passiert ist
hier kommen auch wieder am start das kann ich das kann ich mir wirklich
vorstellen dass das so passiert ist
Dann gucken wir doch mal das hier an.
Warum wird eigentlich jetzt dieser Titel übersetzt?
Also warum werden manchmal Titel übersetzt und manchmal nicht?
Google-Slob.
Ja, eindeutig.
Dann schauen wir mal, was er hierzu sagt.
So ehrlich wie Nvidia hier auf der Computex,
habe ich noch nie eine Firma über KI reden gehört.
Ach ja.
Ja, ach.
Menschen, unwichtig. Es geht um Agenten.
Geil!
Und Revenue.
Profit.
Also, zusammengefasst, die Tokens, die da dank ganz viel Compute hinten rauskommen, bei denen geht es nicht darum, ob man...
Ja, die machen halt kein Marketing mehr für Konsumenten.
Ey, ich sehe wirklich kaum noch Nvidia Gaming Sachen.
Also auch keine Sponsorings und sowas, wo Leute irgendwelche Nvidia Karten empfehlen und vorstellen und sowas.
Ich habe auch schon ewig, gut das liegt aber auch daran, dass ich auf YouTube nichts mache, ja,
schon ewig nichts mal per Mail oder so gekriegt.
Und man sieht auch so gut wie nichts.
Die machen wirklich wenig in der Richtung gerade.
Also man könnte fast vermuten, Gaming geht ihnen so ein bisschen am Arsch vorbei.
Stonks!
Das sieht aus wie ein Teil deines Stockpreises.
in die KI-Rechenzentren.
Das ist, was es so sieht, wenn man komputiert.
Je mehr man kauft, desto mehr man macht.
Und das führt dann dazu, dass eine...
Ja, und Nvidia auch.
...vier Jahre alte PC-Konsole nicht billiger wird,
wie sonst immer in der Technikgeschichte, sondern teurer.
Und zwar viel teurer, gleich mehrere hundert Euro.
Und AMD bringt sogar wieder Prozessoren für die...
Genau, das habe ich auch gelesen.
... alte AM4-Plattform raus, damit man den alten DDR4-Speicher halt weiter benutzen kann,
statt viel zu teuren neuen zu kaufen.
So, und jetzt kommt das Krasseste.
Also, man kann ja durchaus sagen, dass Nvidia den Personal-Computer-Markt so richtig ins Taumeln gebracht hat.
Und dann kommt jetzt Nvidia auch noch um die Ecke und sagt,
Hey, der alte PC, der ist tot.
Jetzt gibt es von uns den neuen PC.
This is going to be the new...
Hab ich statt gerade Windows XP gesehen?
Jetzt gibt es von uns den neuen...
40 Jahre persönlicher Computing.
Ich habe mich verändert, aber Windows XP war das letzte Windows aus einem Guss.
Was sich so angefühlt hat zumindest.
Wir werden die persönliche Computer-Kompetenz wiederentwickeln.
Ich habe das Mikrofon nicht nah genug dran.
Vielleicht liegt es daran.
Alles normal?
Ja?
Ja, wie jetzt?
Warte mal, das muss ich jetzt mal gucken.
Ne, wenn ich so rede, ist eigentlich alles da.
Da wird nichts unterbrochen.
Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht hatte ich das Mikrofon einfach auch nicht nah genug dran.
Das kann schon sein.
R-T-X-Spark.
Und da ist Microsoft mit im Boot und da sind wirklich alle großen PC-Hersteller mit dabei.
Okay, also ich glaube, hier gibt es von mir jetzt viel journalistisch auseinanderzunehmen.
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerin, liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Plante ihr einen neuen Rechner oder wollt ihr euren aktuellen upgraden?
Nein.
Dann solltet ihr auf jeden Fall auf die Qualität des Netzteils.
Bin ich froh, dass ich mir damals einen gekauft habe mit 64 GB RAM.
Wisst ihr, wie schweineteuer das heute gewesen wäre?
Meine Erfahrung ist, wenn bei meinen Rechnern was kaputt gegangen ist, dann waren das meistens minderwertige Netzteile.
Und Qualität liefert Seasonic, die sponsern auch dieses Video.
Seasonic macht wirklich gute Netzteile.
Und mit der neuen Core GX Serie gibt es Seasonic Qualität nun auch zum Einstiegspreis.
Die Core GX Netzteile unterstützen bereits das neue ATX 3.1 Format und bringen einen PCI Express 5.1 Anschluss mit, also optimal geeignet.
Ah, okay. Dann hier, dann brennen die Grafikkarten nicht mehr ab.
Für die neuesten Grafikkarten.
Obendrein gibt es vollmodulares Kabelmanagement, das sorgt nicht nur für Ordnung im Gehäuse, sondern das sieht auch ziemlich nice aus.
Es gibt die Netzteile übrigens in schwarz und weiß, passend zum...
Seasonic hatte mal eine Weile, sogar, ich weiß nicht, haben die vielleicht immer noch, komplett passiv gekühlte, lüfterlose Netzteile.
Da waren sie einer der wenigen, wo ich das mal in Erwägung gezogen habe.
Ansonsten, ich bin ja kein Fan von passiv gekühlten Sachen.
Ja, ich bin der Meinung, lieber ein großer, langsam drehender Lüfter und es ist ein bisschen Luftzug da, als komplett passiv gekühlt.
Passiv gekühlter Sub, danke schön für den Sub.
Huge Subscriptions.
Massive.
IQ Increase.
Jetzt sind wir schon bei 110 heute.
Ihr habt die Wahl zwischen 650, 750 und 850 Watt.
Und was ich wirklich beeindruckend finde, auch die Core-GX-Netzteile kommen mit 7 Jahren Garantie inklusive Austauschservice.
Nice.
Werbung Ende.
Okay, was ist passiert?
Zur Computex in Taiwan, der größten Computermesse der Welt, auf der ich auch zum ersten Mal unterwegs bin,
hat Nvidia die Eröffnungspräsentation gehalten.
Zwei Stunden lang.
Man muss auch vielleicht dazu sagen, dass der Nvidia-Gründer Jensen Wang hier in Taiwan so was wie ein Volksheld ist.
An jedem Inbestand, wo...
Also das ist ja nun wirklich ein sehr ungünstiges Foto, ja?
Sass.
Wo er mal was gegessen hat, da scheinen Fotos von ihm zu hängen.
Also zumindest schien mir das so.
Ja, und es gab im Rahmen der Computex auch, also sagt Chairman Huang ganz stolz, 70 Keynote-Cookpartys, wo eben sein Vortrag übertragen wurde. Bei so einer Cookparty habe ich die Keynote auch gesehen, weil eingeladen zum Vortrag direkt hat mich...
Es gibt quasi Public Viewing für Nvidia Keynotes.
Nvidia nicht. Komisch. Ja, und Nvidia hat tatsächlich CPUs, also keine GPUs, für Notebooks angekündigt.
Zusammen mit Microsoft. Dazu später die Details.
Aber erstmal dazu, was Jensen Huang da auf der Keynote genau gesagt hat.
Und das fand ich ganz ehrlich dystopisch. Das fand ich beklemmend.
Also klar, das Ding fing erstmal an mit, wie wahrscheinlich bei jeder KI-Firma,
die Welt wird besser mit KI und alle Krankheiten werden geheilt und so weiter und so fort.
Man kennt das, aber sobald es dann konkret wurde, da ging es dann nicht mehr um die Menschheit.
Jensen Wang hat sogar gesagt, früher haben wir CPUs für Menschen gebaut, jetzt geht es darum, CPUs für KI-Agenten zu bauen und darum, Tokens zu maximieren.
Tokens, das sind ja die grundlegenden Einheiten, mit denen aktuelle KI-Systeme, also Sprachmodelle, arbeiten.
Und Nvidia und deren direkte Kundschaft, klar, die wollen, dass möglichst viele Leute möglichst viel mit KI machen.
Ah ja, klar, die wollen Kohle verdienen.
In der Realität hat das aber schon dazu geführt, dass Angestellte...
gemacht haben. Die haben einfach sinnlose
Aufgaben an die KI gestellt, dass sie in dieser
Ranking-Liste relativ weit oben stehen.
Das ist einfach
so dumm,
dass es schon wieder lustig ist.
Weil, wenn sowas gemacht
wird und wenn sowas dann auch
Grundlage ist für quasi so
das Ansehen, was man da hat,
ja natürlich machen
die Leute dann Token-Maxing.
Was denn sonst?
Das ist genauso wie wenn du deine
entwickler nach zeilen code bezahlt diese aus kotzen dann wird auch die effekt der
factory manager singleton controller factory global static erstellt ja um eine zeile code zu rappen
MaxToken, genau.
unbezahlter entwickler nicht mindestens eine vierte million dollar
token kosten ja dass der das dass der sagt ist ja klar dass das wird an dem seiner stelle auch sagen
Aber verrückt das ganzen super plan so was du musst machen
wenn die sind da auch in ihrer bubble die gehen dann zusammen golf spielen oder tennis spielen oder was auch immer und erhalten unterhalten sich darüber
und jeder will cool sein mit KI und dann kommt halt sowas raus.
Wenn dieser 500.000 Dollar Ingenieur nicht mindestens 250.000 Dollar mit Token verbraucht hat,
werde ich sehr bemerkt.
Also, wie sie alle da sitzen, ernst gucken und nicken.
Mhm, mhm, ja, ja, mhm, mhm, so ist das.
Dass Jensen Wang und seine Kundschaft das natürlich gerne wollen,
dass die 4 Millionen in Tokenkosten konsumieren, das ist klar.
Aber dass das wirklich so verkauft wird, dass man den Wert von Angestellten in ihrem Tokenverbrauch messen kann, ja, das ist, muss ich leider so sagen, dumm.
Ja, und Jensen hat am Ende der zwei-stündigen Keynote auch gezeigt, was man mit ganz viel Tokens machen kann.
Ein ganz schlimmes KI-generiertes Lied mit einem generischen Cartoon plus typischen KI-Slog-Filler.
Hey, habt ihr Lust auf Karuke oder auch so komisch zusammengeklebte Roboter?
Ja, Resenang, Axelblatt, Confuting.
Ja, und hier in Taipei hat Jensen Wang diesen Token-Extremismus noch weiter getrieben.
Nämlich einfach, Token sind Umsatz.
Okay, also das war so seine Story.
Compute, also in dem Fall Rechenleistung in KI-Servern, die berechnet Tokens und Tokens sind Umsatz.
Ja gut, wenn du irgendein Anbieter bist, der KI-Services anbietet oder für Nvidia.
Also ist Compute auch direkter Umsatz. Das hat er nicht einmal gesagt, sondern mantraartig immer wiederholt.
Tokens sind jetzt profitablere Unikate.
habe ich das im kopf da wurde untersucht welche gehirnregionen bei gläubigen
leuten beim beten angesprochen werden kenne ich ja beim beten angesprochen
werden und was bei besonders gläubigen marken anhängern passiert und es war so
dass bei Gläubigen, die beten und bei Apple-Fans, die Apple-Produkte sehen,
die gleichen Gehirnregionen angesprochen wurden.
Also so Marken-Fanboy-Sein ist in gewisser Weise Religionsersatz.
Also das ist auch die gleiche Diskussion, Xbox vs. Playstation und sowas.
...of revenues.
Chip, Rack, Network, Power, Cooling, Grid
must be designed together from end to end,
because compute is revenues.
DSX Max LPS lets operators safely deploy...
Genau, Gaystation vs. Vixbox haben sie früher immer gesagt beim Flamen.
Das stimmt, bei beiden glaubt man ja auch dran.
...more GPUs inside the same power budget.
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, dass, das gab es aber glaube ich nicht in der Studie, das ist jetzt einfach eine Interpretation von mir.
Also ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass zu Zeiten, wo Steve Jobs und so noch am Start war,
dass wenn du gläubigen Christen ein Bild von Jesus gezeigt hast und wenn du krassen Apple-Fans ein Bild von Steve Jobs gezeigt hast,
dass das auch ähnliche Gehirnregionen angesprochen hat. Das würde mich nicht wundern.
Ja, aber Tim Apple hatte nicht so den krassen Personenkult wie Steve Jobs.
Der sagt es jetzt halt einfach mal so.
Und das ist halt wild, weil das ja wirklich extrem irreführend ist.
Es geht ja schon auch darum, was man mit den Tokens macht.
Also klar, die, die die Tokens verkaufen und die Server erstellen, für die ist das egal.
Aber Jensen Wang tut so, als würden alle profitieren, also auch die, die Tokens.
Wie gesagt, wie ich gerade gesagt habe, das ist, wenn du irgendein Anbieter von KI-Dienstleistung oder Nvidia bist, ja dann schon.
... nur kaufen und Arbeitsplätze würden auch nicht verloren gehen dadurch.
Das sei totaler Nonsens, weil die Mitarbeiter ja ihre Produktivität, Achtung, verdreifachen.
Ach ja.
Ja, das hat er wirklich gesagt.
Ja, Output, Output mag wohl sein.
Aber ob die three times as much sinnvolle Sachen produzieren, ist mal dahingestellt.
Also ich lasse mir gefallen, wenn jemand sagt, okay, Entwickler oder Admins, DevOps-Leute, was auch immer,
sagen wir mal IT-Mitarbeiter,
werden durch KI effektiver.
Ja, das würde ich unterschreiben, das ist auf jeden Fall so.
Dass du jetzt allerdings quasi
drei Jobs machen kannst dadurch,
oder drei,
so viel wie drei Leute,
das bezweifle ich.
Aber das ist genau das,
was andere Leute
in diesen Positionen hören wollen.
Die lassen sich dann auch vom Hype teilweise voll mitreißen.
Und dadurch steigt der Gewinn und die Arbeitgeber stellen dann natürlich auch neue Leute ein, wenn der Gewinn steigt.
Ja gut, irgendjemand muss ja auch ein bisschen den Vibe-gecodeten Kram aufräumen und verstehen noch.
Wenn man einen Software-Ingenieur hirten kann und 9 Trillionen Dollar mit produktivem Arbeit erzielen kann, warum würde man nicht mehr Software-Ingenieure hirten wollen?
bei den Nicht-Bullshit-Jobs.
Bei irgendwelchen Leuten, die den ganzen Tag
Excel-Tabellen erstellen und so. Und gerade
auch im Management-Bereich könnte ich mir das tatsächlich
sogar vorstellen.
Der AI-Cleanup-Specialist.
Die haben sich nämlich einfach das
Commit-Volumen auf GitHub angeguckt.
Also, wie viele Code-Änderungen
Ja gut, da sind dann so tolle Projekte dabei, wie Bunn Transition von Go, ne Blödsinn, SICK, von SICK zu Rust. Warum, weiß man nicht genau. Meine persönliche Meinung ist, weil Anthropic zeigen will, wie geil KI ist.
Ansonsten hat das irgendwie keinen wirklichen Mehrwert, dass BUN jetzt in Rust programmiert ist.
Weil es besteht ja zum größten Teil sogar aus komplett unsafe Rust.
Es ist quasi sick in Rust.
Das stimmt, aber ich überlasse es mal euch in den Kommentaren,
ob das sinnvolles Zeug rausgekommen ist.
... der Commits auf GitHub wirklich 1 zu 1 mit Produktivität gleichzusetzen ist.
Und sowieso, dass sich da in der Rechnung nur Softwareentwickler wiederfinden,
also die Leute, die zweifellos heute am meisten mit KI sind.
Vor allem KI macht ja teilweise auch gerne riesen Commits.
... dem anfangen können.
Es gibt aber etliche Berufe, bei denen gibt es ziemlich sicher gar keinen Produktivitätsgewinn durch KI.
Sowieso schien mir die Nvidia Keynote halt so von Milliardären für Milliardäre zu sein.
Ja, genau.
Das sieht aus wie ein Teil deines Stockpreises.
Stonks.
Ich bin da offenbar nicht die Zielgruppe.
Ich finde KI zwar technisch ganz interessant und beschäftige mich beruflich viel damit,
aber ich verdreifache damit definitiv nicht meine Produktivität.
Und warum Tokens für mich profitable Werteinheiten sein sollen, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht.
Also das schien mir jedenfalls alles sehr abgekoppelt von der Realität zu sein oder zumindest von meiner Realität.
Ich möchte ja auch nicht die ganze Zeit nur rumhaten. Ich fand tatsächlich ein Beispiel aus der Keynote wirklich sehr interessant. Hier so, ich habe die Klappe von meiner Fernbedienung verloren. Die sieht so und so aus. Machen wir mal eine CAD-Datei. Und dann baut der KI-Agent mithilfe der CUDA-X-Bibliothekensammlung eine Datei, die ein 3D-Drucker frisst und dann kann man sich das Teil einfach ausdrücken lassen.
Also dahinter steckt halt die Idee, dass man spezielle Bibliotheken und Frameworks zur Verfügung stellt, die explizit von KI-Agenten bedient werden können.
Das könnte tatsächlich sinnvoll sein, auch wenn ich nicht wirklich weiß, ob das unbedingt Cuda-Bibliotheken sein müssen, die ja nur auf...
Ja doch, muss es für NVIDIA schon.
NVIDIA-Hardware läuft.
So, aber jetzt noch zur interessantesten, zumindest halb konkreten Ankündigung von NVIDIA.
Ab Herbst sollen Windows-Notebooks herauskommen, die komplett mit Nvidia-Architektur laufen.
Und bestimmt ganz viel Copilot-Shit.
Also nicht.
Der by the way auch nicht richtig funktioniert, wie wir im letzten Video von ihm gesehen haben.
Nur die Grafikeinheit, sondern auch die CPU.
Das Ganze gab es ja bislang nicht, also zumindest nicht für Windows.
Das Ganze heißt ATX-BARC, also nicht DJI-XBARC, wie diese kleinen KI-Kisten heißen, die wir ja schon getestet haben, sondern RTX-BARC.
ATX-Bug. Das Ganze ist auf ARM-Basis, also das, was Qualcomm schon mit Windows macht und Apple halt mit macOS.
Eben die Konkurrenzarchitektur von x64, also was Intel und AMD machen.
Ja, und mit 20 ARM-CPU-Kernen, also mit Cortex-X 925 und A725 und 6144 Shader-Kernen, also das ist die Blackwell-Architektur,
entspricht der RTX Spark Prozessor einer Endnutzerversion des System on Chip GB10,
also eben dem Chip aus der DJI X Spark.
Die DJI X Spark nutzt bis zu 216 Watt und das ist natürlich bei so einem Notebook schwierig.
Und deshalb wird Nvidia die RTX Spark sicherlich viel optimiert haben.
Aber Konkretes dazu gab es noch nicht.
Nur, das ist der effizienteste Chip ever von Nvidia.
Gut, da gab es ja auch nicht so viele.
Und dass der Akku einen Arbeitstag durchhält.
Zumindest sagt das Microsoft auf einer Webseite zu ihrer ATX-Bug-Variante.
Das Ding heißt dann Surface Laptop Ultra.
Ja, und Microsoft sind da nicht die einzigen, die ATX-Bug-Geräte bauen.
Tatsächlich hat Nvidia wirklich alle relevanten Player im Boot.
Also Acer, Asus, Dell, Gigabyte, HP, Lenovo und MSI.
Dell fehlt vielleicht noch.
Wobei, Dell bei Notebooks, keine Ahnung, ob Dell da irgendwie dabei ist.
Ich überlege gerade, was ich auf der Arbeit habe.
Ich glaube, HP.
Ich glaube, wir haben HP auf der Arbeit, Notebooks.
...generieren können und die KI-Agenten lokal ausstellen.
Ach so, da ist doch Dell.
Der stand einfach vor Dell davor.
Also quasi das, was ich in meinem OpenCore-Video mit einem AMD Strix Halo-System gemacht habe.
Ja, und spielen soll man auch können, aber da gibt es halt leider noch keinerlei Benchmarks.
Und Specs auch wirklich nur ein ganz bisschen.
Also die RTX-Bar-Geräte soll es halt mit bis zu 128 GB Unified DDR5X-Speicher geben,
der einen Durchsatz von 300 GB pro Sekunde schafft.
CPU und GPU sind mit 600 GB pro Sekunde per NV-Link angebunden.
Und ja, das war's schon.
Nvidia sagt, die ersten Geräte kommen im Herbst.
Hier auf der Computex hört man allerdings so ein bisschen hinter vorgehaltener Hand,
dass das sportlich sein könnte, weil es bei Microsoft bei der Windows 11-Unterstützung noch knirscht.
Ja, mal gucken.
Wer hätte das gedacht? Konnten sie nicht schnell genug Vibe-Coden?
Ich finde es auf jeden Fall wirklich interessant, dass durch die von Nvidia mit ausgelöste KI-Manie, also in den Rechenzentren, der klassische PC-Markt richtig ins Straucheln kommt, also wegen der Speicherpreise und dann Nvidia sagt, ey, ihr braucht auch auf euren Laptops richtig doll KI-Leistung und da weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob die Zielgruppe das mitmacht, weil bei den Co-Pilot Plus PCs von Microsoft, da sage ich mal, ist ja die Euphorie eher nicht so.
Ja, das Ganze steht und fällt halt damit, ob man mit diesen Nvidia-Rechnern irgendwas machen kann, was man, sagen wir mal, mit einem gleich teuren X64-Rechner oder einem MacBook nicht machen kann.
Ja, Stichwort gleich teuer, also wie teuer so ein ATX-Spark-Teil...
Das wird richtig ordentlich teuer mit Grafik 128 MB, diesem Grafik DDR5-RAM.
...128 GB werden soll, das ist bislang unklar.
Also ich sehe hier auf der Computex halt vor allem, dass die Hersteller alle 8 GB Notebooks vorstellen, was ja eigentlich ziemlich unnütz ist, weil sie eben preislich mit dem MacBook Neo mithalten müssen, weil der Speicher so teuer ist wegen Nvidia.
Also ist alles schwierig. Ich bin gespannt, wie das weitergeht. Was meint ihr dazu? Gerne in die Kommentare schreiben. Tschüss aus Taiwan.
Exzellent.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, Leute.
Profit haben wir gelernt.
Stonks und Profit.
Toz
Alles von C++ war es.
Nein.
Aber C++ ist halt auch die beschissenste Sprache, die nicht beschissen sein will.
Oder die hässlichste Sprache, die nicht hässlich sein will.
Max, kurz bitte das hier.
AI Transformation Lead.
Ach, eher.
Okay, wir gucken uns das an.
Aber ich muss euch schon mal...
Ich muss euch schon mal warnen.
Ich finde die Videos meistens gar nicht so lustig wie der Chat.
Aber gucken wir mal, vielleicht ist das ja gut
Es waren auch schon ein paar richtig gute dabei
Director of Directors
Sekunde, ich muss das mal hier ausmachen
It sits under all.
AI generates product value. It's product.
AI touches every function. It clearly sits under me.
I think what we're saying is we all own it.
Totally.
Shared ownership.
Distributed accountability.
Exactly. Nobody owns it and everybody owns it.
That is the beauty of technology.
Phase one. Quick wins.
I want everyone to list what AI is going to do for their department.
Let's make the round.
AI auto-summarizes reports.
So it reads those.
What did it seem like?
Auto-onboard new hires.
Wir senden ihnen eine Notion-Page.
AI sendet ihnen eine engaging Notion-Page.
Engagement geht auf.
Auto taggen und Kategorisieren Tickets.
Auto bauen, internen Admin-Panels.
Auto zu den Kunden-Service-Reporten.
Wir können AI automatisch alle unsere Komplizitäts-Checks machen.
Ja, ich hasse das.
Das macht er schon. Wir nutzen Venta.
Komplizieren ist kein Problem mehr.
Das freut uns, um Leute auf High-Value-Arbeit zu konzentrieren.
Das ist eine Sponsore.
Was ist High-Value-Arbeit?
Managieren von AI.
Phase 2. Markt-Expansion.
Die AI wird uns ermöglichen, schneller zu gehen als jeder Komponist.
Wir reduzieren Kosten, skalieren neue Vertikale,
erzeugen Märkte, die wir vorher nicht bemerkt haben.
Was ist die Zeitlinie auf dieser Karte?
18 Monate.
Es gibt niemanden, der das tut, was wir tun.
Nicht an dieser Geschwindigkeit, nicht an dieser Skala.
Welche Märkte spezifisch?
Alle.
Jeder Markt, jeder Vertikal, jede Geografie.
Wir tun Photonic Computation?
Wir tun es nicht.
Was bedeutet das für die Roadmap?
Das bedeutet, wir denken über Silica, über die aktuelle Infrastruktur, über alles, was jemand je erwartet hat.
Die Vision.
Das Universum.
Wenn wir beachten, dass die KI den operativen Kosten bei 40% reduziert,
konservativ 50%,
50%, dann beachten wir einen 10x Produktivität-Multiplier pro Ingenieur.
10x konservativ?
Ja, mit aktuellen Anpassungen, ja.
Dann bei Q3 nächstes Jahr, wir operieren effektiv mit...
Ist das überhaupt möglich?
Das ist wichtig.
Wir sind so schlecht.
Wir sind so, so, so schlecht.
Wir haben immer schlecht.
So, how's the backend?
Backend?
What backend?
We don't even have a plan.
According to the timeline, all the tests are ready.
Tests?
Das sind doch Typen,
wo er auch schon mal Videos von hatte, oder?
So ungefähr ist das wahrscheinlich auf diesen Events wirklich.
Was kriege ich hier wieder für Videos angezeigt, Alter?
Das interessiert dich sicher, Max.
Okay, brauche ich mich das anzuklicken?
Schauen wir mal.
sie auf 10 plus plus jahre plus bloß ja genau
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt neue Updates gibt.
Weil ich habe jetzt immerhin seit 3,5 Stunden
schon keine neuen Pakete bekommen.
Oh, schon wieder nicht.
MonkaS, so outdated.
Ich fühle mich so outdated.
Ragebait für dich.
Oh ne, oh ne, ne, ne.
WTF, das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Das geht nicht.
Das ist unmöglich, dass ich mir das angucke.
The Story of C++.
The World's Most Consequent...
Was heißt denn consequential eigentlich?
Dass es konsequent wird, dass der...
Okay.
Okay, was auch immer.
The official C++ story.
Das halte ich nicht aus.
Eine Stunde elf.
C++.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Da raste ich aus, weil...
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Ich glaube nämlich, die Mikrowelle ist an.
Mal kurz schauen.
Oh Leute, Leute, die Mikrowelle ist an. Gleich gibt es Essen.
Big Shuck
Ich dachte, der hat was Neues
Das ist ja schon uralt
Da denkt doch heute schon keiner mehr dran
Man's Not Hot
Das ist ja schon wieder so outdated
Overrated
Moin Max, ich werde Vater.
Ach.
Ich bin mir da immer nicht sicher, wenn das jemand so schreibt.
Soll man da jetzt gratulieren oder nicht?
Weil es gibt ja Leute, die sind mega happy.
Und es gibt welche, die sind...
äh...
Särtge.
Und hatte ein Gehaltsgespräch, wo mir quasi gesagt wird,
ich werde abgezockt und wechseln schlau ist.
Will er aber jetzt nicht in der neuen
Probezeit landen mit neu geboren?
Ja, das kann ich verstehen.
Das kann ich verstehen. Ehrlich gesagt,
ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie es mit Probezeit,
Kündigungsschutz während
Elternzeit oder so,
falls so das aus sieht. Ich habe keinen
Plastenschimmer.
Kann ich aber nachvollziehen.
Würde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht machen.
Fühlst du dich denn abgezockt?
Ich meine, die können ja viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Vielleicht war er vorher bei Googlen
und hat irgendwie eine Null mehr hinten dran verdient und so.
Oder bist du zufrieden damit?
Weil,
ich meine, mehr geht immer.
Es ist halt die Frage,
ob du auch ohne, dass der dir das gesagt hätte,
irgendwie unzufrieden gewesen wärst.
...
Teamleiter, wenn dir das
dein Teamleiter gesagt hat,
dann soll dich mal dein Teamleiter dafür einsetzen,
dass du ordentlich mehr Kohle kriegst.
Das war sein Job.
Hast du die letzten Tage die ganzen Gameshows verfolgt?
State of Play, Summerfest?
Ich hab...
Nee.
Ich hab nur ab und zu mal ein bisschen so Übersichtssachen gelesen.
Ansonsten...
Nix.
Guild Wars 3 wurde angekündigt, hab ich gesehen.
40% ist doch erst einmal
am Anfang nicht verkehrt
Achso, kriegst
mehr krieg ich nicht
Ja, der soll sich mal ein bisschen Mühe geben
10% von wenig ist meistens auch nicht wirklich viel mehr.
Dann müsst ihr halt gucken, dass es dieses Jahr 10% gibt, nächstes Jahr 10% oder danach wieder 10%.
Nee, du musst dir nicht dumm vorkommen.
Du musst selbst ein gutes Gefühl bei haben.
und wenn du sagst
du machst dir da Gedanken
aber es hat wirklich keinen Sinn
dann irgendwie so in Unsicherheit
da sich jeden Tag Gedanken zu machen
und gerade jetzt wechseln
hast du denn überhaupt ein Angebot
oder hast du das geschrieben
weil jetzt neue Jobs zu finden
ist ja aktuell auch gerade gar nicht so einfach
Wer würde es gut finden, wenn Max ab und zu Games streamt?
Das Problem ist, ich würde ja, ich würde ja, ich würde ja.
Das Problem ist nur, dass ich aktuell überhaupt keine Games spiele, die irgendjemanden interessieren großartig.
Ich spiele aktuell wieder Herr der Ringe Online, das juckt kein Mensch.
Ab und zu spiele ich mal Orksma Style 2, das interessiert auch kein Mensch.
Wenn es ja wenigstens irgendwas wäre, was früher noch thematisch auf YouTube gepasst hätte,
Wenn ich wenigstens Battlefield 6 spielen würde oder so.
Aber ich spiel halt nix.
Was irgendjemand interessiert.
Okay.
Dann machen wir ne Umfrage.
Mit exakt diesem...
Wisst ihr was? Ich mach keine Umfrage.
Weil...
Ich will mich nicht beeinflussen lassen von dem, was ich streame.
Wenn es mir danach ist, mal wieder eine Runde Battlefield 3 zu streamen oder so, mache ich das.
Oder wenn ich Bock habe, mal wieder, was weiß ich, wenn die neue Dark Season rauskommt, da ein bisschen zu spielen, dann mache ich das.
Nee, ich mache keine Umfrage.
Wartet, ich mache mir keinen zweiten Kanal.
Nee.
Muss alles hier gebündelt werden.
Und außerdem, ab nächster Woche gibt es ein paar Sponsor-Streams.
und ich hab da auch eine mindest mindest stream zeit die ich erreichen muss das heißt wir werden
auf jeden fall den nächsten monat über die die streams in am wochenende und unter der woche ich
habe nicht so eine große mindest mindest stream zeit wenn ich da vier wochenend 44 aufwachen
streams mache und dann noch ein zweimal unter der woche stream habe ich die mindest stream
Zeit schon erreicht. Das ist kein Problem.
Casino Streams. Ja, ganz
bestimmt. Ne, ne. Es gibt
aber dann einen Link,
bei dem man relativ günstig
Festplatten kaufen kann.
Oder, na, Festplatten, weil ich die
Storage-Sachen kaufen kann.
Was ja aktuell nicht verkehrt ist.
Gibt's gute Preise.
Aber nur über meinen Link, Leute, dann.
doch eines eines davon ist ukraine eines der sponsor streams ist ukraine
promo code erzähle ich dann ab morgen
oder promo code wird dann auch die nächsten tage wird es einfach immer im stream titel
stehen
muss ich dafür was machen du kannst den link den nächsten monat über einfach
benutzen wann es danach ist es gibt keine gewinnspiele oder irgendwie so
blödsinn einfach link anklicken und dann gucken was sie gefällt und was kaufen
aber das zeige ich euch morgen dann
das heißt wir brauchen auch ein bisschen
wir brauchen auch ein bisschen themen für streams die was mit technik zu tun
haben und da habe ich ja glücklicherweise schon einiges wir bauen uns wir bauen uns
ein box cluster mit den zwei ukrain nassus wollte ich nämlich schon die ganze zeit mal
ausprobieren wie das ist ob das ob das taugt ja ich weiß sie sind nur zwei man sollte eigentlich
drei nehmen aber drauf geschissen sponsort aliexpress mann ins stream übrigens weil jemand
gefragt hat, ich mute mich immer
in den Sätzen. Eben habe ich mich wirklich gemutet, weil
es kam gerade mein Essen rein.
Ich muss jetzt gleich auf was futtern.
AliExpress, AliExpress würde ich mich
sofort sponsern lassen, Alter.
Die sollen einfach
einen Shopping-Stream auf AliExpress
sponsern. 500 Euro
AliExpress Shopping-Stream.
Da bin ich sofort dabei.
Kann ich mir endlich wieder mal
neuen Technik-Kram, Gebastel-Kram kaufen
bei den China-Chinesen.
Können wir mal ein
SUS-Admin-Bastel streamen?
Open Cloud ist geil.
Was ist... Ach, das ist die...
Ist das die...
Dieser Next Cloud?
Der Next Cloud Fork?
Ich bin überhaupt kein Fan von Next Cloud.
Oder was?
Achso, nee, es gibt nicht Nudeln mit Lachs, es gibt Spaghetti Bolognese, aber jetzt haltet euch fest, mit veganer Bolognese.
Also mit veganem Hackfleisch drin.
Und ich muss sagen, ich fritte in letzter Zeit tatsächlich vermehrt Fleischersatzdinger.
Und es schmeckt gar nicht schlecht.
Wobei ich war ja hier am
Ich war ja letzte Woche Dienstag
War ich hier bei Iron Maiden auf Hannover
Äh auf Hannover
Alter in Hannover
Auf Hannover das hört sich an wie Frankfurt Bahnhof Slang
Bei Iron Maiden in Hannover
Und auf dem Weg waren wir bei
McDonalds ich hab seit keine Ahnung
Acht Jahren oder so mal wieder McDonalds gefressen
Und da hab ich
keinen veganen Burger gefuttert.
Aber ich hab
vegane Chicken Nuggets mal probiert.
Und soll ich euch was sagen?
Die veganen Chicken Nuggets haben exakt
wie die normalen Chicken Nuggets geschmeckt.
Weil das ist eh schon zusammengepresster Kram,
wo du nur noch die Panade und den Dip schmeckst.
Vollkommen egal.
Die könnten da auch Klopapier reinmachen,
würdest du keinen Unterschied merken.
Kannst du mir dann individuell
adressierbare LED-Strip und WLAN.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Aber dazu braucht man erst mal AliExpress
Sponsoren.
Max, ist dein Fahrrad
maxed out?
Was meinst du genau?
Moin.
Was meinst du genau mit Fahrrad-Maxed-Out? Also ich habe mein Fahrrad ein bisschen getunt. Ich habe eine größere Kassette dran gemacht, als eigentlich standardmäßig erlaubt ist.
Ja, standardmäßig ist es nämlich nur 11 bis 34 Ritzel.
Und ich habe eine, glaube 11 bis 42, ne 42 oder so drauf.
Und das geht gerade noch so.
Da kann ich ein bisschen leichter den Berg hochfahren.
Aber ansonsten ist da jetzt nicht sonderlich viel.
Achso, mein Fahrrad ist übrigens kaputt.
Das hab ich euch gar nicht erzählt, oder?
Diesmal bin ich dran schuld
Ich bin auf so einem Schotterweg runtergefahren
So, keine Ahnung, 5-6% Gefälle
Super, super huppelig
Und sonst was, hat sich richtig krass durchgeschüttelt
Und irgendwann hab ich festgestellt
Ich kann nicht mehr richtig treten
Also vorwärts treten ging nicht mehr
Da hab ich einmal zurückgekurbelt
Und dann ist mir komplett die Kette runtergeflogen
und dann habe ich das Fahrrad mal,
bin ich angehalten, abgestiegen, habe mir das angeguckt
und dann habe ich festgestellt,
dass höchstwahrscheinlich, zumindest sieht es
für mich so aus,
die Schaltung verbogen ist.
Also nicht das Schaltauge, sondern wirklich unten die Schaltung.
Und ich vermute,
ich weiß auch woran es liegt,
da lagen ein paar größere Baumstümpfe,
Äste und Steine auf dem Weg.
Ich bin zwar an allen vorbeigefahren, aber ich glaube,
ich bin wahrscheinlich
etwas zu dicht vorbeigefahren,
sodass hinten
von meinem
von der Schaltung
dieser, wie heißt denn das?
Dieser Arm, der halt schaltet,
dass der gegen den Stein gehauen ist und sich verbogen hat.
Und ich hab dann die Kette
wieder drauf gemacht, aber die Kette
ist hinten immer wieder runtergesprungen,
weil die Schaltung so verbogen war.
Vielleicht auch nur das Schaltaug,
aber ich glaub die ganze Schaltung.
Nicht der Umwerfer.
Der Umwerfer ist das vorne.
Ich mein hinten halt,
die eigentliche Schaltung unten.
So, und die Scheiße war, ich habe mitten im Wald gestanden.
Sechs Kilometer bis zur nächsten Straße.
Da bin ich mit meinen Schuhen.
Ich habe ja so welche zum Klicken.
Die haben, ich zeige euch das mal.
Wie sowas ausschaut.
Ja, sowas hier zum Beispiel.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach mal irgendwas.
Nehmen wir mal sowas.
Huch, hä?
Ich will es euch einfach nur zeigen
So das Ding ist
Bei den Schuhen
Alter
Bei solchen Schuhen ist das Ding
Also ich habe oben, ich habe keine Klettverstöße
Ich habe so Dinger zum Drehen
Aber ihr seht hier unten die Sohle
Von den Schuhen, die ist komplett
Steif
Damit kannst du nicht abrollen
Und damit bin ich 6 Kilometer durch den Wald
Geeiert und habe mein Fahrrad geschoben
Da haben mir richtig die Waden danach weh getan
Und dann habe ich mir einen Uber gerufen und bin heimgefahren.
Weil, wisst ihr, wenn der Reifen platt ist oder so, das kann man ja noch fixen, wenn man eine Schlauch dabei hat.
Wenn man dann ein Tubeless oder so hat.
Aber eine verbogene Schaltung unterwegs fixen, das ist halt eher nicht so das.
Written in Golang, aha.
Okay, Chat, ich schreib mir das mal auf
Vielleicht, das machen wir, das gucken wir uns an
Open Cloud
Und ich, und ich
Cloude, sondern Cloud
Next Cloud
Fragezeichen, ich mag Next Cloud nicht
Irgendwie so wird dann der Titel vom Stream
Das machen wir definitiv nicht heute
Vielleicht machen wir es tatsächlich morgen
Weil am Morgen muss ich ja mal ein paar Streamingstunden vorlegen, damit ich meinen Sponsor-Stream-Kontingent packe.
Ne, heute kein Stream mehr. Ich heb mir das alles auch für nächste Woche, wenn dann, wenn dann, also für den nächsten Monat.
Du nutzt aktiv Open Cloud für meine Bewerbung.
Was hat denn die Bewerbung jetzt mit Open Cloud zu tun? Gibt es einen Streamingplan?
Sonntags ab 9 gibt es Streamingplan. Das ist der einzige Plan, den ich habe.
Oder verschickst du deine Bewerbung und schickst dir einen Link zur Bewerbung und der Link führt dann auf deine Open Cloud Instanz oder wie darf man das verstehen?
Gut.
Chat.
Wir gucken mal kurz eine Sache.
ähm
irgendwelche Leute gibt, die wir
hosten könnten.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht. Also ich will ja auch immer einen Channel
haben, den ich kenne.
Pirate Software.
Naja gut. Den will ich nicht unbedingt
hosten.
Der Rest
kenne ich nicht.
Language Deutsch
Da hat mir letztens der Chat gesagt
Das war Weirdchamp, als ich ihn gehostet hab
Wobei ich die Videos gerne gucke auf YouTube
Aber hier gibt's nix
Language
Deutsch
Aber das stimmt gar nicht, oder?
Pike Coding Agent
Besucherzähler
Was Wiener Sportstätten Besucherzähler
Warum wird das
Grafana Dings
gestreamt, hä?
Ja, was auch immer
Wisst ihr, ich bin echt
vorgeschädigt, ne?
Ich hab hier gelesen Scrum
Erstmal gedacht, der Sprint ist gerade angesagt
Gerade
Sprint-Retrospektive durchgeführt.
Chat, wir sehen uns morgen.
Ich geh jetzt was futtern. Ich hab brutales Hunger.
Macht's gut. Bis dann.
See you.